Four,
three,
two,
one.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's right.
Baby.
Uh,
headphones or no headphones.
Headphones.
Grab them right there.
Be a God damn professional,
sir.
That uh,
what,
where'd you get that?
Well,
I just noticed she,
like,
she answered herself up.
I'm very politically correct.
Yeah.
But she'd be like,
yeah,
sure.
I went in.
I batch.
I'm Jimmy Choo's.
Yeah.
Call my chef Darya.
And so she's like,
I think she spends a lot of time alone
maybe.
And she's crazy answering or so what is
going on with her voice?
Because she didn't have that voice when
she was bruce.
It's a different voice,
is it?
I thought it was pretty similar.
It's like what's different?
It's will hire or something.
It's like numb.
Like her face is numb over in wash.
I thought she was.
I watched you.
Did you see her show?
I am cait.
She had like a reality show.
Which bob mean how much of a boring
person you have to be.
When I think how interesting is like an
ex Olympic athlete turns into a woman
and you're still boring still.
No one wants to see that show.
She needed a better producer.
Seems like I put her in.
Interesting situations is boring.
Like I watched it.
I tried to watch it.
It was boring.
God,
I feel like there's.
I just feel like they've missed a
formula.
Look,
that is a fascinating situation.
Until they're 60 years old and then
becomes a man.
Yeah.
How could that show not do well?
How could it?
I think what happened was she wasn't
open about what her transition.
It wasn't about that.
Oh,
she didn't really talk about,
you know,
she,
she doesn't believe in gay marriage that
that's when I like,
I was on her side and they're like,
yeah,
she's a,
you know,
why not?
I mean,
what,
how she said it more.
I'm kind of a traditional or not
traditional girl shower.
Yeah.
Ellen is a very,
maybe one of the windiest very witty and
she went like this.
Well,
how she was completely lost for words
because it's.
It makes no sense.
It's.
Well,
Ellen held their feet to the fire and
they're big feet.
She,
she,
she burned those feet and I have my
[inaudible] teen Jimmy Choo or the fire
bribery of those custom,
right?
Oh yeah,
they'll,
we're around.
Sure.
I,
um,
you know,
for her to be against any group that
she's been,
she knows what it feels like to be
shunned or unbelievable.
It's just crazy.
She's just decided that she's a woman.
Yeah,
a Republican.
All lesbians grow.
But she's a lesbian now.
Yeah.
But now I date men bribery.
Does she?
He or she is dating a trans.
Jesus.
Okay.
What is happening?
Imagine if you were a man.
Okay.
And then you became a woman and you
dated a woman who became a man.
What in the fuck is happening?
You're like,
you're like one of those Yin Yang
spinning through space.
Yeah.
And then you're like,
gay marriage has grown.
Like I'm going to judge that.
It's,
it's,
they need to cut her brain open and
figure out what's,
what's going on.
There's a lot of confusion and a lot of
wanting to fit in.
A lot of,
you know,
it just doesn't make any sense.
And I really like people going through
that.
And I don't want to hurt anyone's
feelings.
I just think she's.
She's kind of an asshole.
Oh,
this is her boyfriend,
girlfriend.
So the girlfriend used to be a boy too?
Yes.
Fascinating.
That is.
Wow.
Wait a minute.
Girlfriend used to be a board.
That's what she used to look like.
Oh Christ.
The world is so strange.
And then she's like,
I just,
she's not a great person.
I mean she killed that lady with her car
and then said nothing like that was the
weird.
You see the footage?
No,
she,
it's looks completely her fault.
She bumped into this lady who was
stopped and the lady went across traffic
and died.
Yeah.
And no one talked about it like I was
putting on my land.
Calm in the mirror.
Didn't share.
Is that what she said?
But she was looking at her phone.
I don't want to see this.
Oh,
I'm going to feel bad.
Yet some poor lady died and no one,
no one gives a fuck.
Because the story is not that.
The story is she's a woman now.
She's always been a woman.
I mean,
it was good timing for her because
people like ignored that and sort of
went well.
It's crazy timing.
That was broche yeah.
The video that you did have that.
Why did you start doing these videos?
I'll tell you,
I was having like midlife crisis panic,
waking up at three in the morning,
like really moments.
I was writing for the show.
It was last year and it was great job.
Everyone's really nice and I like
something in my subconscious felt like
I,
I don't know,
like I had to get out and I,
I quit the job and I was like,
I'm just going to make videos on
instagram.
Like what a,
what a great business move.
May Lose my health insurance and make
videos for free on instagram.
Dude,
you have the funniest page on instagram.
I haven't seen them all,
but if all the ones I've seen without a
doubt,
you have the funniest page.
I'll thank you very,
very much.
I mean I went because of you from like
$20,000.
No,
240 something.
That's awesome.
You and uh,
you know,
in Thompson written well,
it's also like pumped it up.
It's just how good they are,
man.
It's one of the viral once,
once people watch a few of those do the
one that you did where she was
describing the different utensils that
chooses to get herself off with the weed
whacker.
And Oh my gosh.
Tooth.
Oh yeah,
come on to help me out.
I gotta finish till when did you start
doing the face swap thing?
Is it you're using your face to face
swap app you can download and there's
one for the trump.
I just,
I was doing trump at first night though.
Look anything like him.
So this was like a way to do character
and have that clarity.
Trumps is stormy Daniels once epic.
Stormy.
How'd you get my number?
Oh,
the other one that made me cry was Kim
Kardashian and trump what?
Kim couldn't figure out how to open up
the door and wait for the buzzer.
There's the weird buzzing noise.
That's where your push it.
Oh,
uh,
those are um,
take so long.
I don't think anyone spend as much.
So I'm making videos for instagram.
Kim.
Okay.
I'm at the side door.
I bless you in Dolores.
Yeah.
You gotta push it.
It's a locked.
Yeah.
We're delighted.
Buzz you.
Okay.
Push it.
What did you opened it?
There was the weird thing,
the message that debates opened the
door.
If you have to.
What?
You have to wait until a buzz.
You.
Jesus.
Great.
But I just got here.
No,
go in the door,
but I can't go in the door at the stolid
shit.
But
that would have been a lot funnier.
Biogenic.
Oh,
that's what I do with my time.
A grown man.
Yeah.
You're an actual full grown man.
I'm an old grown man.
I'm a man.
Boy.
So you really just decided to start
doing these full time.
It just like,
it wasn't even like a brave decision or
anything.
I really couldn't sleep.
I was having panic attacks that I was.
I think I saw my future and it was like
I'm going to be a writer writing for
people for the rest of my life.
You,
you get addicted to the money and the
insurance and all that,
and it happens to so many comments.
It happens like I and I heard about it
and I didn't see it coming and it just.
I suddenly woke up last summer,
I'm like,
I have to stop or I'll do this forever.
There are a few friends of mine who are
really,
really funny comics and then can't work
because they spent so many years doing
sitcoms as a writer or doing sketch
shows as a writer that they don't have a
following,
a following in the road,
but they're world class comedians.
Do you know Owen Smith?
Yeah,
he's fucking hilarious.
Nobody knows who he is.
I'm like,
dude,
you're one of the 20 best comics in the
world.
It's crazy.
It doesn't make any nice guy.
Great Guy.
Ian Edwards.
Same Shit.
I mean more people known to Ian now than
before,
but God says,
trust me,
it's a fucking trap.
Only so much creative energy and if
you're giving it to someone else,
you're done.
It's not just that you're tired all day,
you're stuck in an office and then you
have to go on the road.
Like if you want to be a comic,
you have to do sets multiple times a
week and you've got to go on the road.
That's just the way it is.
There's no way around it.
There's no other way to do it.
If you get in your fifties and you're
not famous,
you don't have a decent following.
Like you're,
you're fucked,
you're screwed,
you're fucked and lets you run white.
Like Ron White got famous.
His late forties,
he was living in Mexico in his forties.
Oh really?
Done.
And then Jeff foxworthy contacted them
and they started doing that blue collar
comedy tour and boom.
Now he's got a private jet balling out
of control.
Yeah.
Big Fat House in Beverly Hills.
Ooh,
sweet Rodney Dangerfield till.
Yeah.
Well he quit.
He quit doing standup was selling
aluminum siding.
Oh,
that's right.
And then came back,
but the entire time he was away.
He was writing,
which is really crazy.
So he came back with a fuck load of
material and also came back with a
sharper style like came back more
edited,
more precise.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's,
that's where it changed.
I feel like I can't believe how old I
got.
Like you don't notice it if anyone's
listening.
They're like in their twenties.
You don't get you.
I'm 40,
I just turned 47.
I'm 50.
Yeah,
you're further along than me career
wise.
So I'm not as worried about you.
You don't wake up with night terrors
deal,
but you did,
Huh?
Yeah,
I really did.
When there are certain moments like you
know,
you don't think about being old,
but like,
like when you put the date of birth in
online to buy something like that.
Scroll scrolling forever life going by.
You born in 70,
71?
Yeah.
That's a good year for cars.
You're the pig last good year for cars.
Is that true?
Yeah.
What about a tesla?
What do you hate?
Tests?
I don't know.
I mean muscle cars,
like my American muscle cars.
Yeah,
like the 19 sixties to the nine to 1971.
Nineteen 71 was essentially the last
good year for cars.
We like Muslim ban.
Me and Joel both ripped,
but you know,
to share those classic American cars.
There was a few years where they were
unbelievably cool and then after like 71
they fell apart.
So you just,
you caught it at the perfect time.
That's,
I mean that's what I'm known for.
Being born right at the end of the
muscle cars.
Seventy one barracuda.
That was probably the last year.
A big car guy.
I love cars.
Yeah,
I do too,
but I drive a Honda civic because that's
what I could afford.
Well,
I had a Honda civic wants to.
Yeah.
They're great.
They start up every time you need them
to.
Yeah.
I've had a fifth of their fucking shit.
Those cars.
Every time you put that in,
there's no confusion.
No problems,
no worries.
No anticipation.
Come on,
baby.
Come treated like crap.
It doesn't matter.
Those things are bulletproof.
Yeah.
They last forever.
And of Toyota's I have Alexis.
I love those things.
They never fuck up.
I'm on the waiting list for the Lexus.
Hm?
No,
I'm sorry.
Tesla.
Oh,
which one?
The three.
The new.
The cheaper one.
The three?
Yeah,
three.
Yeah.
But it's still like suspiciously
expensive.
Do you see what's going on with Tesla
and the formula employee,
some employee was,
was sabotaging code and a leaky
information and now the employee is
saying,
um,
that,
you know,
trying to say something about the Elon
Musk was there was waste that he was a
whistleblower.
He's not saying he's a saboteurs of
whistleblower,
but they were saying he's a disgruntled
employee because he owed money.
It's become this gigantic thing.
And Elon Musk is suing this guy stealing
code and then giving it the it.
No,
I don't know the exact specifics of it,
but he did something,
did something bad.
I Dunno.
We hate that guy when like,
oh,
well that car is like,
it's like it's 35 grand,
but if you want tires,
it's 45 to 75 grand.
Right?
Yeah.
You want a tesla,
you know?
Mm hmm.
I just need,
I need more.
I'm thinking,
think of it starting like a fun so I can
get a tesla.
You know,
people have like charity that go fund me
Patrion where you just commit to doing
one of those videos every x amount of
days.
I'm hearing about the.
I got to get into the business side of
things,
but a problem is creative people rarely
are business minded.
I'm spending like $4 a month on just
phone calls.
I'm not making to like a t and t and
stuff.
I need to like get get my business side
in order.
What do you mean?
I know you keep,
you'll get a subscription to something
you don't use anymore and then you
don't.
You can't figure out how to cancel it.
Like,
oh,
that's happening in my life.
Oh Man.
That's what they.
That's what they want.
Yeah,
they're good at that.
I want to make it difficult for you to
quit.
He had like,
they'll go,
hey,
have these vitamins.
You get one month free and then before
you get the vitamins you have to cancel
in order to stop the next month from
being charged.
Is them saying,
Oh,
you know,
I'm like,
I'm up on my guitar right now.
Let's move on.
Sorry.
No,
it's okay.
I get it.
Yeah.
So when you do these videos,
um,
how many,
how many hours do you think are involved
in like,
like the Kanye one,
the one,
the most recent,
which is fucking hilarious.
Thank you.
I um,
I've gotten quicker at them but it still
takes
uh,
inordinate amount of time probably
because there's like I get the idea,
nick,
I'll write something quick and then I'll
sleep on it and then I'll go work on a
little more.
Try to edit it down because you want to
make it like pretty tight with like
online people don't want a minute of
fluff or anything.
So you got to go quick.
Yeah.
And the actual process of,
of getting them to talk,
I'll take the person who talks the most,
like if it's Caitlin and I'll,
I'll film that and I'll have the whole
script written out so as I feel it in my
mouth all talk the other words.
So the timing is kind of close to that.
And then I'll send that video to myself
to my airdrop it to my laptop and turn
it really low and then I'll do the next
character and have that playing so I can
have that sinked up.
Right.
And I compare those to do the next
person like that.
Whoa.
Get a lot of time on my hands.
Yeah.
But I'm only 47.
So.
So what was the thought process when you
quit?
You just couldn't do it.
You had to,
you had to get out.
Yeah.
I,
I just um,
something was the,
like a panicking it,
this was I think seeing my life and I,
I want to at least try to be like a
performers.
Why?
What I wanted to do,
I can't even read very well.
And being a writer to me is um,
it's not as fun.
I mean,
if I didn't have the experience before
and like,
um,
I don't think I feel this way,
it's just I got a taste,
you know,
I had some stuff that I did that I
really enjoyed it just,
I think I just saw the,
the trappings of it.
Well,
some people are really good writers in
the,
that's what they want to do,
that's all they want to do.
They don't want to perform.
But the problem with being a good
performer is sometimes you can help
other people out.
Like,
Hey,
if you just tighten this up here and
maybe if you just explain this a little
better,
it would work better and you know,
you,
you start writing,
next thing you know,
hey,
would you work on my show?
Sure.
Then you're there in the office and
you're got a corkboard and you're
putting index cards up and you're like,
oh my God,
yeah.
And then I'll get that check every week.
And you're like,
oh,
it's a nice check.
Sweet.
And I,
I'm really thankful for those jobs.
And they were,
they were really great and I,
you know,
I have a house and stuff,
but uh,
yeah,
this is like last power drive I think.
Fuck it.
If this doesn't work out with Instagram,
I mean just this though,
I'm really excited because now I can do
little theaters.
Like the draw directly from instagram
has enabled me to like get out of clubs
and stuff,
so it worked and I feel the audience,
like I just had chosen San Francisco and
it's such a difference when the audience
knows what you do and who you are
instead of like having to take them
through.
Well you might be one of the only guys
that's done it that way though,
through characters in little short one
minute videos.
Yeah.
Because I really,
I started off with that but then there
was no money in sketch really,
you know,
and so I got into standup,
I needed to make
money and so I never felt standup was
what I did the best.
But now I feel like I'm getting a little
better at stand up and I'm actually
enjoying it more now.
But it characters and impressions is
when you do shows,
do you ever play videos?
Do you play that?
You did a show?
I have a show at Largo that I do like
every couple months and I did show
videos.
It was the owner's idea.
Um,
and that was really fun.
It's a great idea.
Yeah.
Especially if you make some videos
specific to the show.
That's exactly.
I didn't do that,
but,
but watching,
I was like,
that's what I should do.
Like have trumpy like next step guys,
ethic or whatever.
Yeah,
yeah.
Having the host.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
have a tailwind,
generous take on different things and
just,
you know,
Caitlin's tips.
CAITLIN's.
I did a thing where she,
I brought her out,
like in between as she's working on a
one person show was just the idea,
like the greatest love and when had the
like audience surfed,
it was really fun.
Oh yeah.
I mean you could do easily like some
sort of a multimedia presentation type
thing.
Yeah.
It seems like it would be a really great
idea.
Yeah.
I'm trying to put together something
[inaudible] to do like some kind of
special.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Just sandwich bits in between,
you know,
like to do some stand up and go,
and you know,
like,
you know,
I wonder,
I wonder what stormy Daniels would do or
you know,
just anything.
I mean,
any weird way the community decide to
transition.
What did you get the story?
Daniel's voice is.
It sounded anything like,
I have no idea how she thought.
She was like,
Beth,
oh,
I can't wait to get your cock in my
mouth again when she's calling.
She actually sounds nothing like that.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
But it doesn't matter,
but she seemed like she was like,
oh my God.
There was one that you did that look
like your face.
You jerrod cushner.
Was that it?
Like me.
He's like,
um,
but all of our face swap.
None of them are you.
I do a character craig.
That's like,
oh,
that guy with the glasses.
Yeah.
Checking Matt.
That's my real mom.
Probably know that.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
She's a good actress.
The first take,
she didn't know what I was doing and
that was like real and honest.
But after that,
like I told,
she knew she was acting.
She seems very good.
Yeah.
It seems like you're annoying the shit
out of your mom.
Yeah.
It's very funny.
So when you decided to do this,
there's no.
I mean,
unless you're a hot chick selling
whatever,
what do they sell?
Sunglasses,
assumptions,
makeup detoxes.
Skinny tea detox.
Kenny t?
Yeah.
Unless you're.
I've never made a fucking penny off of
instagram.
I mean that you have it either will.
I've actually just ticket sales I guess.
Right?
Yeah.
But yeah,
I haven't
monetized or I haven't been thinking
about that.
I just Kinda,
I feel good if people like,
it just makes me feel like at some
purpose or something that I feel like
I've done something and I'm building.
If I could build an audience and to come
to my shows,
I'll be really happy about that.
So you were
doing mostly clubs before and now you're
moving into theaters.
Is that what's going on?
And this is all over the last months
from instagram.
That's incredible.
It is.
So it worked it here's success story.
Well,
I mean it's working.
It's working.
Yeah.
That's fucking great.
It's really exciting.
And thank you again.
I mean I might share my personal Santa
Claus Dude,
my fucking whole family.
So sick of watching your video.
My wife got angry,
the other,
she was in the toilet and I was like,
just watch.
I opened the door,
go watch this,
watch this one,
watch this one.
Because with the Kanye West when I was
crying,
she's like,
what the fuck are you laughing at?
And I was like,
watch this.
Just watch this by worst impression,
but the fuck up.
Amazing.
It was amazing when,
when Caitlin's like,
shut the fuck up cam.
He's a junior.
Can check genius at work.
Can.
Oh,
oh.
The other one.
The other one about the baby died in her
womb.
Which triggers.
Yeah,
I'm pregnant.
Too babyish.
Could breathe in the room.
Yeah.
Shabnam up my new badge.
Dad.
Do you have a womb?
Let me go.
Crap.
They shout probably Gad,
but then they go immediately to the
lipstick.
Ugh.
It's just so perfect because like
instagram,
it's almost like you have optimized
instagram better than anybody.
You really have nailed it.
You've nailed it.
For comedy.
It was everybody else like mine
included.
If you would go to my instagram,
you have to fucking dig to find out.
I'm a comedian and you got to go looking
around.
You can,
you know,
you can find anything there.
All kinds of stuff.
I take a picture.
I find a picture.
I think it's cool.
I put it up there.
There's no rhyme or reason to yours is
like a show,
like your instagram page.
Kyle Duncan one.
You got to go to wash my neck.
There was a kyle,
Donnie.
He's gotten all my gmail accounts.
Who?
He grabbed everything and I asked my
nephew.
I'm like,
what?
Because over Christmas I'm like,
I'm just going to do instagram videos
and see what happens.
And I was like,
what should I do different?
And he's like,
she take the one out.
Stupid kids ones are.
Yeah,
it's stupid.
Why'd you and change it now?
How about the Real Chi?
I don't.
That's the thing.
Marketing's not my thing though.
I am kyle done again.
That's another one.
People do call on in comedy.
It would have been fun.
That's a good one.
But it's a lot of words.
A of letters.
Yeah.
It's A.
I think instagram,
just like in my wheelhouse,
like I like to edit.
I like to do quick,
you know stuff.
No,
it's perfect.
But your channel,
your page is like a channel unlike most
people's instagram pages and treat it
like a show.
Yeah.
It is like a show.
It's almost like you should have a
regular.
I'm that you shouldn't even.
He'd just keep doing what you're doing
because you don't have videos now for
Instagram TV.
You could go up to an hour.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
But I think what he's doing is perfect
instagram TV.
Yeah,
it's a new thing.
Just came out.
Oh boy.
I just got a panic attack.
Thinking about doing an hour of Caitlin
for an hour.
40th five more.
Manage everybody.
Fuck.
Oh Shit.
I just spilled coffee all over the
studio.
It's okay.
You're not going to do it all the time.
No laptops or anywhere near killed a
bunch of laptops,
man.
Nothing about Mac.
That pisses me off.
Guess what,
Lenovo?
You spill on it.
Nothing happens.
Nothing.
They make them waterproof.
Then make them dust resistant.
They make a mil SPEC.
We need to spill on them.
You could throw a glass of water in the
keyboard.
Not a goddamn thing happens.
You put one on apple.
They just tell you,
nope,
you're gonna.
Need a new one new one.
Blow on it.
We need a lot more napkins.
It's okay.
If you sneeze on it,
it'll.
It'll blow out.
Sons of bitches want to go grab some
Napkins.
Hey,
grab a couple of those.
Kill cliffs,
those line ones.
I'm very uncoordinated.
Dude.
You're not this.
I do this all the time.
I'm pretty coordinated and I fucking
spill coffee and here all the time.
It's,
you know,
it's your microphone's in front of you.
Start moving your hands.
I'm a fucking.
This is your,
uh,
what is your background?
Mostly Italian.
One quarter.
Irish.
I'm the same thing.
Shut the people are cool.
It's crazy.
Twenty three and me.
I did that now,
but I'm doing it right now and I'm doing
a bit about it because I'm secretly
hoping that someone in my past has sex
with a black person.
I have,
I'm hoping two point seven percent
really nice,
but I think it's northern African.
Let's,
I'll take it,
I'll take it and I'm going to run with
it and it'll open up a whole new realm
of material.
Just bring your 23 and me and it's going
to start shitting on white people.
So hard to be a white guy.
That's the hardest thing to be.
So polite,
man.
She had no one to blame.
So always.
That's true.
It's your fault,
but it's also the easiest thing to be.
Of course.
I'm just kidding.
I know,
I know.
You're kidding.
You don't have to say you're kidding.
You're fucking comedian.
How dare you.
You're still cleaning.
You don't have to clean anymore,
man.
I'm still cleaning teeth.
The thing is,
the more coffee that's on this table,
the better it looks.
It's going to smell good.
Yeah,
weathered.
This is a weather table.
Give me that.
I'll chuck chuck that the garbage.
All right,
thanks.
This.
This coffee has character or this table
rather character high maintenance.
No,
you're fine dude.
So you got to have some measure of
satisfaction that this moment that you
had that cause he.
I love stories like that because you had
this moment where you're like,
I can't,
I gotta do something,
I can't do this anymore.
And then you did.
And it worked.
Yeah.
I,
I'm really,
I'm sleeping a lot better and you know,
I had,
you know,
been in this business for a long time
and there's been so many.
I mean,
I could talk for hours about the
disappointments,
but I still feel lucky,
you know,
that it got,
I was able to like make a living or
whatever.
But uh,
there's some luck involved.
I mean,
I was lucky you came across it and um,
I've had so many.
I wish I knew who told me about you.
I wish I could remember.
It might've been Tom.
Tom,
yeah.
Tom Was Tom.
He was pretty.
It was a comic.
Pretty sure it was a comic.
It might've been Tom.
He was the first one to host one of
mine.
Think maybe that's what it was.
I did this show.
Oh,
I,
I won't go into it,
but let's just say I have so many
disasters.
Don't write thought.
I was like,
get ready for the rocket ship Kyle,
go the shopping because things were
about to take off and just always
something.
I did this Jamie Fox,
like a sketch show pilot and it took to
get up a part on a network show.
It's a lot of auditions if you climb a
mountain to get the role and I was like,
feeling this is my last shot and
everything and I got there and we
couldn't.
We weren't allowed to write for
ourselves.
Blood is a wga rolls or something and
you know,
you have a character.
No one else can really write for it.
And the people that were writing,
two of them just got out of prison and
they were not comedy writers.
Jamie is a huge career.
He didn't really.
He just was like,
let me get my friends this because I got
all this other stuff going on and he
didn't give a fuck.
I need it now.
He would show up like once a week.
No.
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah,
he's busy.
I need to come in.
He come in with glasses like Shay and
we'd go and we'd read the script and
there'd be no ending or seemingly point
and then one time he threw the script
and there was like,
fuck that script.
Do you,
you do you,
you know,
when he walked out and the executives
were like,
no,
you can't do.
It was like,
that was like,
he climbed this mountain,
there's an Arby's at the top,
just like the thing that was going to
be.
These writers called me into their
office once and they were like,
yeah,
we have this idea for these,
these guys who never wrote a sketch
before.
And they were like,
this idea that you're,
you're Jimmy by James Bond,
you're Jimmy Bond,
all right.
And you're,
you're in an airplane.
Right?
And like to take it,
take it.
And the next day I'd be like,
yeah,
and you owe like a soda,
like a,
like a coca cola or sprite or like a
point that I got to get a mountain dew,
mountain dew or Die Co.
And I'm like,
uh huh.
And then that was It.
I just was sitting there dead silence
and then we had like this show which
came out very mediocre was what was it
called?
It was called into flow.
It got changed to something else and it
just became like,
it was a fee on crockett's show.
I was like a hot,
like a cast member or whatever.
And then at the end,
you know,
fox pays all this millions of dollars
and a few hands going,
all fox cares about is their wallets,
but we showed them not realizing we had
to wait for a pickup and I'm just
standing on stage thinking this is my
last shot to have anything because I was
already like 40 and I just was like,
let me go to the wrap party.
And the whole thing was just me and
eric.
Andre is on it too.
Okay.
So we just were like,
what is Happening?
And we go late to the wrap party and we
walk into this nice restaurant and jamie
foxx is standing up and into the whole
one big table and he was going down.
WhAt's your favorite animal?
What's your favorite animal?
It was like a rabbit,
like everyone.
Just those.
What's your second favorite animal?
What's your second favorite animal is
terrifying to fuck.
Yeah,
and he goes,
he goes,
the first animals who you think you are
the second animals who you really are.
I told tom cruise that.
He saId it was awesome.
Anyway,
it's instagram.
Yeah,
I have a.
I'm going to write a book one day.
I just called humiliated stories.
A long career of ground balls.
I've,
I've had so many like why really was
going shopping for houses,
had to stop several.
Like I had this pizza hut campaign which
was like get ready to like open up
several bank accounts and it was like
the big new yorker pizza and you know,
there's an explosion of flavors as we're
shooting nine slash.
This is a campaign of videos.
Nine slash 11 happened as,
as we're shooting the explosion.
It was just the wrong vibe to be like,
hey,
New York,
a big explosion of flavor is this whole
thing.
And so they canceled the whole thing.
They played like,
I don't know if like a month they played
a few and then they like dropped it,
but he was like,
you know,
it was I shot for,
I got paid pretty well,
but we're going to do six more.
It was going to be like one of those
flow from progressive pizza hut.
Guy of subway.
Yeah.
For pizza hut.
That you were going to be the verizon.
Can you hear me now,
guy?
That's what I was waiting for.
That trust that guy anymore.
No,
I don't.
Please switch to.
where's he at now?
Sprint.
That's not cool.
Yeah,
I don't hear you as well.
My,
my mother walked into pizza hut ones
while this campaign was happening and
she just pointed at me.
She was my,
my,
my son's pizza hut.
Oh.
And I had to tell them I'm,
I'm actually not pizza hut anyway,
so I feel lucky.
But,
but uh,
but you found the thing like,
look dude,
you're fucking videos made me howl.
They're really,
really funny.
Like that's you,
you for whatever it is.
The way your mind works.
It works best for these face swap
videos.
Which,
which is fucked up man,
because it didn't exist until.
When was it?
Two years?
How long ago?
How many years ago?
Three years ago.
I remember I'm the first person I ever
saw use it was chris delea.
Taleah was.
He did some video where he was rick from
the walking dead and he put it on his
instagram page.
I was like,
wow.
I'm like,
obviously I can tell something's going
on,
but that's amazing how close that is.
Yeah.
I was excited right away because I knew
that the impressions that I do,
I don't look like most of them.
To your trump is fucking phenomenal and
when you do it with that wacky fade,
the one face that you picked for the
face wipes so perfect because it looks
like he's out of control.
Crazy.
Jesus.
That's fucking amazing,
man.
It's amazing.
Did you see the.
What's going on today?
Tom arnold,
who hates trump,
has a new show on vIce or he's just
running around trying to find
incriminating video and audio w on
trumbull.
That's all he's done.
The whole show is him on a quest to find
incriminating and humiliating video.
And audio and trump.
And he was with Michael Cohen today.
What?
Yes.
How could he.
Michael cohen is apparently going to
work with tom arnold on the show.
Oh,
is he?
Is the fbi okay with that?
I think they were together.
This photo.
I mean tom arnold could be just
bullshitting.
well,
I'm tv knowing that that's coming out.
You're stIll tivo going.
Why don't you just get out the vcr?
Do know how to work the client.
Now I have things come out of my mouth
where it shows my.
What is this jamie on his twitter.
This is tom arnold.
Did the miss universe tape is another
tape talking about 16 year old girls in
their underwear here.
The celebrity apprentice.
Trump.
Denies any involvement with
cute.
Don't worry tom arnold.
Tom arnold
for the trump tapes with tom arnold.
I mean,
no one's going to care no matter what.
He uh,
no.
It's not going to have an effect.
Probably.
Listen.
Fuck john gotti.
Trump is a teflon done.
You see that movie?
they're
saying they scammed rotten tomatoes.
Would that move those to be the greatest
movie of all time will get a zero credit
80 from the audience and like 90 percent
where it was from like their employees
thinking that correction on the michael.
Wow.
When was that taken as a correction?
Some sort of correction it.
He didn't say.
Me and him were teaming up to take down
Donald Trump.
Michael has enough trump on his plate.
I'm the crazy person who said me and
Michael Cohen,
we're teaming up to take down trump.
Of course.
I meant it.
Michael doesn't get paid by vice.
Okay.
Thank you tom,
for correcting the record.
Thanks for clearing that up.
Bam.
That's what I feel like he was.
Tom arnold.
I'd be nervous as fuck.
Why?
I don't want to get killed.
Oh,
now.
Impossible.
You can't kill tom.
Arnold would have putin did it for a
favor.
Poot and might be able to do it.
Put some little decides I don't like.
We'll do.
Doing what could you have done?
This is not that good.
The russian accent.
Would you consider doing a poo on your
page?
I will,
yes.
That's a good idea.
It's a great idea.
Let's use the lotion that has these
little.
Shouldn't this good?
It's not bad.
just do it.
Just listen to him talk a few times and
you'd.
You'd get it.
I'm putting good and then a bunch of
like really harsh russian prostitutes.
Like water flying squirrels.
That's it.
Next week.
Yeah.
I mean that's not a bad idea for a
sketch.
Is there a piece of tape or is that a
that a rumor or do we not know this?
I don't know.
I don't think it's supposed to be real.
Think it's supposed to be fake.
I.
It sounds fake.
It sounds like something someone would
just make up,
like not even well planned out.
Who?
How many?
What percentage of people like to be
peed on?
It's got to be below one percent.
That's still a lot.
It's 300 million people.
That means 3 million people or to get
peed on just in this country alone.
That's a lot of cleanup.
I don't even think it's one perCent,
but even if it's one 10th of one percent
is 300,000
people.
Like,
I love a chocolate sundae,
but if you smeared it all over the
place,
then after I had to clean up I'd
probably back.
You know,
I'm not into that.
I think it's a freakish thing you're
into.
I'm surprisingly team.
I'm not in anything freaky.
I've never even done like whipped cream
or anything hot about.
When a gIrl asks you to choke her a
little,
how do you feel about that?
Um,
that's a scary.
It requests.
I'm not into that.
I'm not.
Um,
I had a girl that I used to date who
wanted me to rape her.
She told me the raper that's hmm,
that's
tough and problem with she was fucking
hot and I was like,
I do not want to get interested in doing
this.
Like the worst thing would be you really
liked that because I was in my twenties.
What if,
what if I just had it came after I got
into like only girls that want you to
like force them to do shit.
That's,
that's very true.
When you are young and you're forming
your sexuality,
whatever,
you first got your.
Like when I first dance with a girl and
I noticed her hips were wide,
I,
I got like a boner and there's like an
eighth grade because it was like this is
different and it linked and four years
till I was in my early thirties I could
not dance with a girl without getting a
hard on.
I was at a wedding once and I asked this
girl to death like I never do this,
but she was alone and she was hot and I
get on the dance sport,
my mother's there and I got like a
boner,
I don't know this girl at all and I had
to tell her because,
you know,
like your wedding pants are,
are not keeping things,
you know,
and so full pitched and I,
she probably already knew.
So it was like,
I'm sorry,
can you help me up off the floor?
And I had to,
how humiliating says I'd asked this girl
to like shimmer me off the floor away
from my mother.
Yeah,
she had a good,
luckily a good sense of humor about it,
but it's not like she.
She,
well I shouldn't say she should be
flattered,
but a grownup.
What sense of humor?
Be flattered.
She invited her halloween party after
that,
which is a good sign,
but that went bad.
I got All dressed up as the universe.
Like I started.
Yeah,
I had like a whole black outfit and I
glued like planets to my body with
velcro,
you know,
a grown man and then I go to her house
on time,
which I didn't realize you don't go to
parties on time.
I just gotten to la and then I went and
I went to hug her.
I knocked over the skeleton on the wall
and their dog ran up and like bit venus
off my leg and took off and now I'm just
in the room and no one's dressed up.
People are coming and they're like,
have abandoned any.
It's like I'm a pirate,
but no one's really dressed up except
for me.
So it was a pariah and then no one
taught me how to put the at the end,
this guy,
because all our friends were like,
frat guys.
He goes,
can I ask you a question?
And I was like,
yeah,
like,
oh,
someone's talking to me.
He goes,
you got no.
No was like,
really?
Yeah.
It's like,
now I'm in.
This all started with me getting a boner
with this girl.
But anyway,
I gotta go jesus christ.
What a dick.
Yeah.
It was kind oF a dick.
Was he a dick before that?
Yeah,
they were all kind of like a jockey
jockey and they were drunk and I think I
seem like a target because I had the
universe on my body seemed like an easy
target.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's a severe weakness.
Unless you were doing something.
I mean they.
Why wouldn't they think that was funny.
Like,
what are you doing man?
What's with the outfit?
And then you start talking
to.
You start laughing.
Everybody has a good guy.
We would've had a good time.
Yeah.
You forget.
You know,
that's funny though,
the boner thing because there was a girl
that I dated when I was in high school
and she,
she was into like rubbing her feet on me
and I had a foot thing for a long time
and that's because of it.
What,
where was she rubbing her feet idea.
I meant like where you at your house or
whatever.
She would just rubber feet on my legs
and put her feet on my girlfriend.
Yeah.
I used to go to this math class,
10:30
ugly teacher,
but her smell boner every time and I
knew I was like,
oh,
I gotta go get a boner in this class.
That's hilarious.
But that is a real thing about like
getting connected to like an a
particular thing,
like whether it's choking someone or any
of that guy,
that girl,
the girl wanted me to rape her.
Also would grab my hand and put it on
the back or get me to force her head
down.
She was crazy.
She was just really into it.
Yeah,
but it took a while for her to warm up.
It's almost like when we first started
fooling around,
she was like,
come on,
don't tell them this motherfucker what I
like normal.
Then one day she wanted to russell.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just like a gateway.
Drugs like what?
She's like,
I want to wrestle you.
I'll kick your ass.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like what are you doing?
Theater up.
You lost.
I didn't,
I didn't.
I didn't beat her up,
but I was trying to figure out what
we're doing while we're doing it.
And she turned in sexual.
She got into it.
Yeah,
I think like,
like louis ck.
I like,
I remember his show,
like one of the first episodes he had a
show wrote,
got older girl asked him to jerk off in
front of her and I was always like,
I bet that actually happened and that
got linked up and you can't really
decide what links up your sexuality and
what it is that turns you on.
It just could have.
I have no information,
but that's my guess if people are into
weird shit man,
during the weird shit.
I think the weirdest is.
This is this smelling the shoes.
Oh,
marla maples,
trump's x put a camera in her bedroom
because she kept in her closet because
she kept.
She didn't have one shoe and it was some
friend would come in the economy just
like just coming in and stealing,
sniffing ashish christ.
Zakat linked up.
Oh.
anyway,
yeah.
There's a lot of that stuff,
right?
Like stealing underwear,
stealing shoes.
Men is.
Men get picked on because we're pervs
and.
And that's true.
But if we weren't pervs this species
wouldn't be.
Or let me tell you why,
because we were down to like 70,000
people if we didn't have this super per
game to go through the snow,
get some pussy.
I think it's less than 70,000
people.
They were saying that after
one of the super volcanoes it might've
gotten down to is just a few thousand.
No.
Well,
there was a definite.
What does it sumatra?
Is that where it was?
Indonesia.
Some,
some massive super volcano 70,000
years ago.
Killed oFf almost everybody.
Oh,
I didn't know about that.
We got down to extremely low number.
I think they,
they estimate it's somewhere between
like two and maybe like 10,000
people.
Yeah.
You need people who liked to bug a lot
that are real curvy,
curvy.
Jump that up.
Well,
you know,
bret weinstein,
who is a.
Yeah,
he was a professor.
The zoo,
sorry,
what's going on with man?
I smoked weed before the show.
I'm not gonna lie to you people.
Um,
he um,
was explaining with his wife who's also
a biologist that there's two different
things that men are attracted to.
They're attracted to a beautiful woman,
but they're attracted to a hot woman.
like a hot woman doesn't necessarily
have to be beautiful,
but what she does is offer an
opportunity for like very quick sex.
Like you could just have sex with her.
You don't have to court her like a girl
with a short skirt and her tits are
popping out and she's wearing a lot of
makeup.
That what that signals is that there's
an opportunity for you to spread your
genes and you have no responsibility.
You wouldn't have to take care of it.
You wouldn't have to.
You wouldn't have to spend a lot of time
with her court her that she was,
she's the type of person that allows you
to just fuck her.
You can move on and spread your genes
elsewhere.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
That there's like an evolutionary reason
for that being a stimulating thing for
men,
for men like this idea of like these
loose women like loose women are very
attracted,
very attractive to us for that reason.
It's not just that like,
oh yeah,
fine,
get some.
Not deal with all these bitches in
there.
No.
It's literally an evolutionary trait
that we have adapted to
the disease thing.
Knocks it back a little bit for me.
I'll go like a disease there.
Anecdote,
anecdote,
an antidote for.
Cause I,
I don't feel like there's any woman who
could,
no matter how hot like come and,
and,
uh,
take me away or like a forced me to
like,
what am I trying to say?
So deuce me.
Wow.
Here it is.
I think a woman could seduce you.
Now if I don't want her to.
I have an anecdote.
Anecdote.
I have an antidote and it's,
I've been development over years and
people that can,
uh,
listening can take this if you like.
Let's say you fell for somebody and she
liked him,
she dumped you and you're still pining
over her.
Put her first.
You'd like think about like the blood
moving through her body and her and her
skeleton and you put her on the toilet.
I think about like she's making bio.
I know this is gross,
but that's.
You think about her as this animal and
you think about her on the toilet.
Whenever she pops up,
you put her on the toilet.
You're welcome.
That doesn't work with me.
It will.
I won't care.
No,
no,
no.
If I think she's hot,
but she's really struggling on the
toilet.
I was struggling the toilet so you could
not judgmental.
I take,
I eat a lot,
man.
I take some horrific shits.
But think about like the bachelorette or
something.
They're there.
Fantasize a lot of times early on
there's this fantasy and,
and uh,
you know,
you're,
you're married.
Yes.
So you're,
you have,
there's intimacy and you get past all
that.
But that early on fantasy make filling
in the blanks as a perfect person.
Usually leave that out.
It never bothered me.
I don't.
I don't give a fuck about periods.
what about thinking about the skeleton?
Anything?
Does that kind of go,
oh yeah,
if you just imagine there's a skeleton
underneath this woman that I'm like
pining over.
She's just like,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't work on me.
It works for tell you man.
If I think someone's hot,
they're hot.
I don't care if they just took a
diarrhea shit.
How about this?
I imagine they have bad breath.
I'll be like,
ah,
but she has bad breath and I'd tell her,
oh,
you're aussie.
I just say,
listen,
I'd say something really nice.
You're super hot and I'm going to tell
you something.
compliment sandwich.
You start with a nice thing and then
then you go up against yourself or go.
Sometimes I get bad breath and because
I'm a person,
everybody gets bad breath.
But when I get bad breath,
I want someone to tell me absolutely do
not want to be wandering around.
Grossing everybody out and they're like,
hey,
good to talk to you joe.
As soon as they turn their head,
tell me.
I don't know.
I'll,
I'll take a listerine strip or chew gum
or whatever the fuck some people go
ahead.
So I would tell her,
but some people have an pr,
like,
here's an example.
I was with this girl and I could not
take the breath.
Couldn't take it that bad.
And then I said,
hey,
let's brush our teeth.
Was either it was either you gotta go,
I can't do this.
I've got to figure out how to brush our
teeth.
So she brushed her teeth,
reluctantly,
reluctantly brush my teeth clearly,
but it didn't fix it at all like it was
coming from our gut.
Some people have like,
you know what?
That happens with a lot of girls who
would believe or yes,
even anorexic or they gerd,
they regurgitate and bodies all fucked
up.
Your body's like super confused.
Him as a data girl puked.
I didn't know it until like,
like deep into the relationship you had
to is a couple months and then I found
out she was just saying like if she eats
too much,
she'll force yourself to throw up.
and I was like,
why?
It's easy to hide.
That is.
I mean I knew it existed,
but I didn't know anybody who had it and
that's a disturbing thing.
Like you ate,
you're hungry,
so you eat and then you're like,
well,
what have I done?
Yeah,
shove things in your mouth and force it
to come up again.
God,
did you guys talk about or that sort of
end,
the relationship
new moved away?
No,
no,
no.
She brought it up and I said,
well she did.
This was the fucked up thing was she
wasn't in any way overweight.
I,
she was beautiful.
she had great body.
She just,
it was just like a weird.
She was an actress,
you know,
and I think that that per the pressure,
that gig is just so crazy.
It's just,
first of all,
you take someone who,
most of the time,
the reason why we want to become an
actor is because they didn't get enough
attention.
That's a lot of what causes it.
Especially if you have like this weird
sort of nonspecific desire for fame.
It's not like you.
You're a really good character actress.
You know you're a faye dunaway or
something like that.
You just really good at.
You love the craft of creating a
character.
Now there's a lot of them.
They just want to be famous and why?
Why is that?
It's usually there's something fucked up
from childhood.
Usually somebody wasn't paying attention
to them.
Parents split up.
Something went wrong.
Right?
So you take this person that's super
insecure and as as exorbitant need for
attention,
and then you put them through this
audition process.
The audItion process is the craziest
thing ever.
It devastates people's self esteem
because you just get rejected all the
time.
Rejected all the are.
You're not selling a tee shirt that.
No.
You're selling yourself like,
yeah,
tonight's date.
This girl,
when I first moved to la and when she
would go on auditions,
when if she would get rejected,
she would want to fuck like a wild
animal.
It's like she wanted something to just
like.
She wanted to just fucking scream too.
She wanted.
She was,
it was the stress of it all was so
crazy.
She wanted validation.
She wants to blow off steam.
It was just the stress of it all.
It's so unhealthy and the people that go
into that are some of the most the
least.
It's the least advisable career path for
them.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It attracts the wrong people.
It's just a fucked up situation.
You have these people judging you like,
come on in,
kyle.
Yeah.
I can't tell it.
Tell us about yourself.
A lot of trouble auditioning.
Tell me what your favorite animal is.
That's who you are.
I told her,
you told tucker he loved It at a level.
That's great.
Wow.
Tom cruise.
I want to audition once and this girl
told me.
She asked me where I was from and I said
I was from New Jersey and uh,
she goes,
I'm from New York.
She goes,
well,
I'm actually from New Jersey,
but I don't tell people that I go,
why?
she goes,
well,
it's cooler to say you're from New York.
I go,
that's ridiculous.
that doesn't make any sense at all.
I go,
why would you lie?
and then you just told me and she goes,
are you ready to audition?
I'm like,
okay.
So she's like giving me like the sour
look.
And I had a scene with the audition I
told you.
And then I,
she had a sour look on her face and I
had to sing a line from a bruce
springsteen song to her in the audition.
It was so humiliating.
You auditioning for the band movie some
terrible movie.
It was a singing in the movie where
there's a guy and a girl and you know,
like telling the girl how much a lover
and I'm singing like fucking born to run
or something like that.
I don't even remember.
I think everyone would love to hear a
little bit right now.
We can dream.
I don't remember.
I don't even remember what he didn't get
it.
No,
no,
not.
Not only did I not get it,
but this is very,
very important moment for me.
I left and I real.
That's when I realized I was like this.
This whole process for me at least is
broken.
Like I'm not good at this.
This is not.
I'm not good at pretending to be
someone.
Like everybody who goes in there,
they,
they go into these auditions and there
was these people who were like air
quotes,
working actors.
They do A little,
you know,
I was on just shoot me for saying,
I had a nice episode on this.
You know those people,
they're like hopping around those
people.
They developed this real slick way of
talking and they don't say nice to meet
you because they might already met you.
So they say good to see you.
Good to see as kyle I to see it.
Oh,
it's because I keep remembering,
forgetting,
you know,
dunbar's number.
A certain number of people you can keep
in your head,
but this,
this,
this way of doing it.
I was recognizing it the way they would
talk.
Everyone was like super left wing,
super progressive.
No one explored ideas.
You just adopted whatever everybody else
was going with and ran with.
Oh yes,
I agree.
Hillary is so much more qualified.
He would just.
People would just say shit like that.
It was just.
It was really strange.
They were like real obvious dEmocrat.
They weren't thinking it through.
They had just adopted this mindset and
they were just sneaking their way
through the system.
They were like exploiting little
personality holes in the system and they
would get become friends with casting
agents and one of the casting agents was
a woman I knew this one casting agent
who was friends with a friend of mine
and she was kind of gross and just being
nice,
being kind by saying kinda and she
fucked all these actor guys and she
would want to know who this is.
I cAn't tell you.
She,
she,
she's a nice lady.
She just slipped.
She's.
She was basically doing what,
a lot.
She was doing the casting couch in
reverse.
Right.
But she was like aggressive sexually
aggressive with guys.
Yeah.
And one of my friends,
she's super sexually aggressive with one
of my friends.
Is it a henrietta weinstein?
I can't tell you.
oh well she,
you know,
she was,
she was casting quite a few different
shows and she knew how to.
She knew hOw to get these,
these,
these exploit people,
these guys that were saying good to see
you.
Those guys.
She would fuck those guys because that
was,
that was the way they could play it,
you know,
that's what they get this when her
seduction,
when I don't know what it was.
It'S brutal though.
Auditioning I,
I'm terrible.
I booked one.
I've gotten like sketch shows,
but I've only booked one show where it
was like a script.
A guy.
It was a sitcom.
I booked like a guest starring thing and
I went in and I'm a terrible reader and
for the read through they do a read
through with a network like at a couple
days before they shoot and they gave me
like,
oh you have eight new lines,
whatever,
and I can.
I read like a third grader.
I very poor.
So I the big table read through and I
stammered through the whole thing.
I have fired.
So the only show I booked really off
typical audition,
reading a script.
I was fired from jesus christ.
I mean so many wasted hours memorizing,
paying,
acting coach and none of it worked out
for me.
It was a lie because I get really
nervous.
I feel very judged.
I feel very uncomfortable.
I'm a terrible reader so I ended up like
having to memorize it and then most of
my time is like trying to remember.
It's just basically get too nervous as
well.
Did you ever try to like see a hypnotist
or anything like that or.
No,
but that probably would've been a good
idea because it wasn't mental.
Yeah,
shut down.
Like,
you know,
some people just react,
you can't help how you react,
but it's like if you can imagine,
if you're afraid of bees for example,
it's like go in and audition with a
bunch of bees flying around.
You did your,
your,
your body is reacting in a fear way.
It's really hard to grab your facilities
to act or whatever you're doing to
possible,
you know.
So no,
I get it.
I mean,
especially if you think like this god,
this could be it.
This is the big moment.
One of the worst ways for you to behave
like or,
or to perform rather in something that's
like really important,
especially with an acting situation
where you know,
you're supposed to pretend to be in love
or to pretend to be happy and whatever
the fuck it is.
Like you're,
all you're thinking is don't fuck this
up,
don't,
don't fuck this up.
And that's like the overlying mantra to
all your thoughts
doing it.
Do this.
Correct is not the great mindset.
Were you going to do a good performance?
I like,
I'm A,
just fell out of my head whenever I was
about to say I was going to be
hilarious.
It was the best part of the show was
going to be great.
Yeah,
but this is one of the reasons why so
many people are so crazy out here.
It's like come here crazy and then the
system gets some crazier and then you
also realize that unless you're doing
something like what you're doing or you
just doing your own thing on instagram,
somebody has to pick you to work.
You have to get picked,
which is just nuts.
like as comics,
all we have to do is just go to an open
mic night practice,
you know?
Right.
Come up with some jokes,
do well.
You come back,
you just keep grinding.
Couple of years down the road,
you started to get a gig here and a gig
there.
Yeah.
I'm opening up for this guy and yeah,
I got a gig mc and at this place and
then a couple of years after that,
a middle and a couple of like,
there's a,
there's an actual thing you can do if
you're good,
you can do,
you can make a living.
I can't imagine just being an actor.
Forget it.
They go crazy,
dude.
I,
I have friends that are just actors.
They go crazy.
They all go crazy by the time they're in
their forties,
they're out of their fucking mind and
women.
Oh the,
that they feel like they're,
they feel like they have this little
tiny ass hourglass and it's just running
us and everyday.
Yeah.
And like you said,
it's a lot of times you're not starting
with the most secure people.
No,
almost never.
I never,
I got on stage because I was in so much
pain.
Like I literally like was pushed.
I was in college.
I had like no friends.
I really painting a pretty picture
myself today.
But I,
uh,
yeah,
I wanted like,
attention,
like that really was the first impulse.
And um,
yeah,
but sometimes that leads to the funniest
shit in the funniest people like this,
that pressure one way that throws you in
another direction.
I mean not that,
that bad feeling when you just trying to
escape that bad feeling,
the energy and the desire to escape that
bad feeling is so intense that it
creates a good feeling.
And after a while though it flips to
like,
now I,
you know,
I'm like,
sometimes I don't want to be looked at,
you know,
I think if I got into a bad spot I'd
want to go on stage again.
But sometimes do you ever feel like
that?
Like you just don't feel like being,
like look at me.
Like I'm like,
that's not what happens with you
sometimes I don't feel like going on
stage.
No,
definitely.
I,
uh,
one of the things that I've been doing
lately is for a long time I never,
I hardly took any time off.
But uh,
after I did my special,
I Just filmed a special in april,
I took a month off.
I didn't do any stand up for a month.
Yeah.
At least like three weeks,
right?
Like three maybe.
It might've been Four weeks,
but I was like,
I'm not doing shit.
I went to Hawaii.
I fucking hung out.
I did podcasts.
I didn't do any stand up and it felt
great.
It felt great that I would leave here
and I'd be done.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have another gig to go to at
night.
Yeah,
I know there wasn't this overwhelming
thing looming in the background.
Yeah.
But after awhile I realized,
all right,
gotta,
get back on the horse.
Yeah,
I've been enjoying it more now.
Go ahead.
What's that worries.
I,
you say interrupted you.
You were going to join more now.
He said,
well I uh,
I'm enjoying stand up now like I,
because I feel like this instagram gave
me
a little confidence of bring that into
my standup because I,
uh,
I,
I just kinda was,
I think scared trend to what people
said.
And,
and there was this thing where like,
you got to make it a sitcom.
You got to be.
Talk about your family.
I had managers who were like,
don't do the guitar,
don't do this.
Do talk about your family and get.
They were trying to get you to make
something that could be turned into a
sitcom so they could take it away from
you.
Once your ex girlfriend says you were
shitty boyfriend.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
it's a new thing.
That's what they're doing now.
That's the new thing.
The new thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
there was a lot of that.
There was a lot of.
They were trying to get people to
basically put together an audition for a
sitcom.
You're,
your act is essentially like tim allen
or roseanne or whoever.
What brett butler,
you,
they put you,
you know,
and some people have the confidence and
not to listen to.
I remember zach alpha eczema was one of
the guys who like didn't want to be on a
sitcom,
and I was.
I was like,
I didn't believe him because I'm like,
that's what we all have.
That's what we're all doing.
Right.
But he had like a sense of himself.
I got like out into the world without
really having confidence in myself.
Like to make a decision to do something.
I really felt like I needed someone to
tell me that he does his experiment.
I'm explain this and explain myself real
quick where they did this in the
seventies.
I'd rattle,
rattle in front of a baby and the mom
would do this and baby would like it.
Then that you haven't keep rattling it
and the baby would start to push it
away.
They haven't keep rallying the.
They will start crying.
All babies go through this exact thing.
Then after the crying,
they have them keep rattling it,
which is something they would never do.
Now at the last phase of the baby's numb
out and start drooling.
Jesus,
and that's how I lead came into the
world,
but I feel like I'm waking up now a
little bit.
That's fucking dark that they did that
to a baby.
Only the seven is what they do.
That.
How many people did they fuck up in the
seventies?
I know the brown eyed,
blue eyed experiment.
Remember that this they told a classroom
of kids blue.
White people are smarter and better.
Brown eyed people are to kids.
So then the blue eyed people started,
you know,
doing better work,
behaving better.
The brown eyed kids started misbehaving,
then they switched it to like we were
wrong.
The broWn eyed kids are the ones who are
smarter and better and the whole thing
switched.
So they do it as a psychological
experiment just to see.
Likes to fuck with kid.
Really fuck them up.
Well yeah,
if you tell kids that they're shit,
they feel like their shit.
Yeah.
You don't really need to do that
experiment.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Go do the opposite of that.
I know that we're talking now about like
the effects on kids with the trump thing
and the border.
It's so dark.
It's so.
See what.
What the fuck was melania wearing that
jacket?
Care.
Do you,
do you think care?
What does it say?
I don't care.
Do you think I do or some shit I don't
care to use.
I wouldn't.
Is what is
going on in that house?
I think she's losing her marbles
decision.
Do you think she had any idea when she
married that billionaire dude and 2005,
she thought she was just getting hooked
up.
She's like,
look,
I'm going to have a kid,
but this guy,
it's going to be great.
I don't have to work anymore.
All these fucking nude modeling gigs
that I was doing and you know,
learn how speak a little bit of english,
whatever,
you know,
go shopping all the time.
Fuck yeah,
I'm mad on big good boy,
bad boy,
boom,
I'm in.
And then 10 years later she's the
fucking vice pro.
I mean,
she's the president basically.
Well,
she's more popular than the vice
president.
Oh yeah.
Fuck knows who penances don't know god
damn thing about that guy.
He scares me a little about what might
be the president one day because the
lead jesus stuff going on lot of jesus.
Lot more than ever.
Pence sessions,
huckabee lot of jesus,
chris pratt being praised because he
said people should pray,
which is a legitimate thing to say.
I mean like just whatever prayer is,
mindfulness,
meditation,
feeling good,
you know,
just being thankful.
You know,
you don't have to attach it necessarily
to any I ideology or religion.
It's still a good idea to think that
way,
but people are going,
yes,
we got a christian doctor from fucking
guardians of the galaxy is one of us and
like the idea that no atheist can be
president.
No atheists and no single guys.
Yeah,
better have a family bitch.
Otherwise,
what are you going to do it?
You're gonna fuck everybody in launch
bombs.
Just to see What happens.
That's exactly how it happened.
That is what would happen.
I mean,
could you.
Do you think that it's possible to have
a single guy or gal as the president?
I do not.
I do not think it's possible.
It's got a stigma.
People would get weirded out by you.
How old are you?
You're 49.
You don't even have any kids.
You fucking weirdo.
You don't have a wife.
Even a sing.
Even at guy who's married with no kids.
I think people will be like,
man,
he's not like us because you could be
married with kids and I could be single
and I don't feel weirded by you.
I don't feel like this is fucking
weirdo,
what's he doing on married with kids
because that's a normal path,
but it's not a normal path to be like a
55 year old guy with no wife.
No kids.
Never been married.
Yeah.
No desire to.
Because like when you're,
it seems like you're more stable if the
whole family for sure.
But you have something,
you have some skin in the game,
you know,
you care about your kids.
That's true too.
You don't want to like blow up the
world.
So like that sting song.
If the russians love their children too,
you know,
it's,
you.
We hear a bit of that.
Joe,
I'll sing it for this audition,
but then I'll walk out of here.
I auditioned for snoopy on broadway.
Humiliating a good boys,
but they wanted a comedian or something.
So I guess I'm,
I got
this audition.
The song was like sub sub,
sub per time sub,
sub separate.
Literally I waited my friend john and
John Bush,
comedian.
Uh,
no,
not really.
A funny guy.
He went in before me and I walked in.
I know his name felt like a bomb went
off and I walked out in the hoffman,
well what happened?
He was lIke,
nah,
and I went in there and they were just
dead silent and I did like a whole
dance,
accepts up supper time to people just
staring at me and I left and I was like,
what?
What happened in there?
He goes out of the guide,
said that my audition was cute and I was
going to leave,
but then I walked back in,
I tapped on his table.
I said,
you know what?
You're an asshole.
And then he left and then I was like,
hi,
you're an asshole.
Because you said it was cute.
Yeah.
He's like,
why is everybody sort of defensive
though?
Yeah.
Be snoopy,
bro.
Yeah.
Snoopy's not mad.
Is this bush character?
Is he always like that?
He's.
He's hilarious.
Yeah,
like he Just doesn't like.
he doesn't give a fuck.
He lives in ioWa and Iowa.
Yeah.
What's he doing there?
He's got a nice little.
I've got family in the house as a
corporate stuff mostly now.
Oh,
it was corporate gigs.
Yeah.
That's weird.
That's a weird world.
That world of corporate gigs were the
guys,
they.
They give up mainstream,
but they can do those corporate gigs
that pay really well,
but nobody knows about them.
[inaudible] nobody knows they're alive.
Yeah.
They just.
They just do these corporate gigs.
Yeah,
and you can make some money doing that,
but they're like,
a lot of times,
like during the afternoon,
people are eating food and then you stay
it some best western somewhere.
Oh,
Kansas city.
Just staring at the wall.
What they do to comedians to go look,
get a comedian when the environment.
I'm sure you've had two gigs like that
where you just at a place like,
why did they think that's good for a
comedian to come here?
Terrible.
You've done colleges,
right?
Oh yeah.
The kids are on it.
like these 17 year old kid.
I went to one and they had a poster of
men,
but they didn't put the date or the time
on it.
Guess how many people showed up?
Million.
A million people.
That's amazing.
That's great.
HoW'd you do?
I did.
Fantastic.
I asked him one time I was at amhurst.
Oh no,
it was a giant field.
There was one guy in a red hooded
sweatshirt and the center of the field
sitting indian style and I said,
I don't have,
we don't have to do this.
Right.
And she goes,
no,
just go out there.
People hear you will start coming out.
Oh my god.
One guy,
one guy.
Amorous is a tricky place.
That's uh,
that's the people's republic of amherst.
So it's like if you took boulder and you
moved it to western Massachusetts,
amherst,
super,
super progressive and liberal.
I did not know that.
Well,
they don't like comedy launch for sure.
We'll be right back.
That's too bad.
Most people don't know that impression
and nobody knows about just uh,
not anymore.
It's Johnny Carson and back in the day
that age,
you know what I think of,
I think of johnny carson's a fucked up
thing to think of,
but he died smoking like some ungodly
amount of pall mall.
So you just kept pumping on these pall
malls.
Just smoked him constantly and his gut
had become distended,
like you was pregnant
and it was just,
he was as rotten with cancer.
Like his whole body was just fucked up
and apparently like when he died,
like as he was,
as he was dying,
he's like last days he's like,
these goddamn cigarettes.
Oh god,
I didn't hear the cigarettes.
It's all I think of when I think of
Johnny Carson.
I think of him poisoning himself with
these things that he can't keep from his
face.
He just can't.
He's got to keep doing it and his body's
is rotting and he goes from being like
america's favorite all time talk,
show host.
He was the fucking man.
I mean he was the man.
Yeah.
He goes from that to just quitting,
just stomping
to stopping doing it and then it becomes
this weird thing.
He becomes this weird guy.
This reckless what?
What is,
what happens there?
How does,
how does one go from being the tonight
show host to just being a recluse?
Yeah.
He never tried to do anything else,
right?
No.
I like what letterman's doing.
He's doing those things on netflix now.
I haven't seen them.
I haven't either,
but I liked that he's doing them.
I'm worried about him.
I worried he would be one of those guys,
you know,
because he kind of vanished.
Yeah.
Cruise crazy beard and I'm going to do
that crazy beard.
Yeah.
Okay man.
That's cool.
With you guys.
Do you think these guys,
they just like get to the point where
they're like,
I can't do this anymore.
There's just too much people.
Too much pressure,
too much.
A lot of pressure every day to do a
show.
It takes a certain personality,
different kind of thing.
Right.
Exhausting.
I'm sure.
And You're doing standup that's never
been tried and now it can't be great.
I mean,
terrible.
It takes a long time to get an act
together.
That's really good.
So did you hear what happened today in
the news that day that was good about
cars though he would make kind of fun
about how bad he was.
He.
Yes.
Well jay leno was the best at it,
I really feel.
And that's why they extended his
monologue.
So even though he wasn't good,
he was a workhorse.
So every sunday you go to the formosa
beach club?
Yeah,
I did.
I was on that show and I film something
and he brought me into the office and
uh,
he didn't want to air it and he goes,
I just,
I didn't want to get any letters because
like,
I did that craig character and he just
felt it was too,
like,
um,
retarded or something.
Yeah.
He played say yeah.
He played it safe when people swung on
him,
he'd never swung back.
yeah,
he does.
Just roll with the punches.
Yeah.
Would you do a talk show?
No,
I'm doing one right now with one on
instagram.
kyle,
the worst name on instagram.
Why would I do that?
It's,
it doesn't seem like a good way to talk
to people.
It doesn't seem like it's fun.
It seems like it's too much pressure.
It seems like there's too many people.
It seems like the conversations become
fake because you have five minutes until
you cut to commercial and they come over
with cars and the executive wants to
talk to you and the producers want to
get in your ear and.
Well,
can we just feel like,
um,
it just needs a little levity,
a little it.
so we're,
we're going to bring it in.
We're going to bring the gesture out.
Oh,
the child.
But I'm tired of the gesture.
I don't like the gesture and the gesture
comes out with his little.
Everybody was fucking crowd size clap
and the audience they get.
That sign is cheer.
Applause,
applause.
I've,
I've seen too many of them.
I just think it's a dead medium.
I don't like it.
I,
I'm not recommending it.
I mean you have it.
People should see.
Or you should have sTudio tours.
Joe's got the pool table here.
You have to put your vr on.
We've got the vr goggles now with htc
vive.
I don't know what that is.
Vr goggles.
Virtual reality.
I could have figured that out and put on
these goggles and you box.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Big dude in front of you throwing
punches and when it hits you though the
screen goes white,
like really get popped.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's fun.
There's a bunch of.
Um,
there's um,
there's arChery games.
There's a one with a light saber with
things come at.
You ain't got to slice them.
They're flying through the air and when
you're chopping them up,
that's cool.
You want it to music?
UH,
it's fucking amazing and deprivation
tank you got here.
I do,
I do.
I have that to joe.
You want to tell them how we did on pool
today?
We did really good.
It was fun game.
How many balls did I get into games that
we played?
Even made one ball.
I did get a call that you made one.
Got it.
And that's not bad.
went where you wanted it to.
You aimed,
you shot,
you fired.
It went in.
That was really emasculating.
Those two games.
It shouldn't be two things.
One the tAble.
I didn't tell you because I didn't want
to freak you out.
Good.
No.
Very tiny pockets.
The pockets are much smaller than a
normal table.
That table has five and a half inch
pockets.
That table is four inch pockets.
They're actually slightly under four.
Yeah,
so they're really small,
so it's hard to get a ball.
Okay.
And I play on it everyday.
It wasn't hard for you to get the ball
and just want to say that.
I told you I planted every day.
I really do.
I every day after,
after we're done,
I.
That's how I unwind.
We do the podcasts,
it's over and I go knox and balls around
that.
Your best game pool?
Yeah.
I'm not good at any games.
That's the only game I'm good at it.
I'm terrible at video games.
I can play quake pretty good at quick.
Okay.
An archery or good at good at archery,
but that's not a game.
Not game to me.
SerIous bro.
Yeah.
archery is a very different thAn all of
them because archery is like.
It's very much like a meditation,
you know?
It requires so much concentration and so
many things have to be in line that as
you're thinking of all those different
things,
it cleans your mind in some weird way.
Very meditative.
You ever read zen and the art of
archery?
No.
Really good book.
Interesting book.
It's funny because my friend John Dudley
read it and recommended it to me and
he's like,
and he's a world class archer.
Like he,
he just got back from europe where they
flew him out to coach various,
uh,
international teams.
LIke he's a,
like a real world class coach and archer
himself.
And he said,
he's like,
it's interesting you like,
this book is really good,
but I have a feeling that the guy who
wrote it wasn't really that good at
archery.
Oh.
I'm like,
oh,
that's fascinating.
It's like the guy he goes,
I feel like he was kind of there but not
quite.
And I'm like,
that's interesting.
Coming from a guy who's a real master,
like recognizes some something,
some errors in his thinking or the way
describes things or his approach really
interesting.
By the way,
you never have to ask me again.
Did you read that book?
I did not read any books.
I haven't read a book in a long time.
Thank god.
Someone's honest.
I mean,
you could say,
did you hear this book?
Sometimes they'll get an audio book,
download it.
Oh,
I love audio books.
I read one audio or read one book for
every seven or eight audio books I
listened to or read one maybe and I
don't even read most.
I don't even read.
Sometimes I'll start off reading it and
then I'll go,
this is too much work.
I'm just going to listen to it in my
car.
I just listened to it.
I don't.
It's like there's a lot of dead time.
There's a lot of time that's not being
used and that time is when I'm driving
and I'm always driving here.
I'm driving to the gym or I'm driving
into the comedy store.
I'm driving to the airport.
I fill that up with books on tape.
do you do self help books?
No.
Mostly like right now I'm reading,
I'm reading the tipping point,
which is a malcolm gladwell book and I'm
also reading sapiens,
which is who wrote sapiens.
I heArd someone read the book.
The tipping point is great.
It's really great.
Really interesting.
And also felt like,
who is it?
Yuval noah harari.
Oh,
okay.
That's great too.
And also,
uh,
the talent code.
There's another book.
I'm in the middle of the tubings.
Great book.
This book sapiens.
fucking fantastic.
Opiates,
a brief history of humankind.
Very enlightening.
Oh yeah.
That tipping point.
I feel it could have been three
sentences long.
Yeah,
it was.
It was a little,
you know,
there is.
I get it after awhile.
Like I got it.
I got a bunch of things collide together
and anything can happen.
And the next thing,
no hush puppies are really popular.
My tipping point was joe rogan played my
instagram videos.
Not crazy.
Yeah.
That's the only tipping point that makes
me very happy.
I love doing that.
I am.
I will always.
I will if you need.
This is just between me and you.
If you need me to murder someone or you
need some favor.
Good dude.
Good.
But I'm going to contact you in behalf
of Donald Trump to deal with it.
You really are worried about the time I
was going to kill time on the floor.
It might be.
I don't know what,
what It is.
Consumer now take it back.
When people do kill themselves,
you gotta go,
okay,
how many times did this person think
about this?
Like,
how,
how many times did they get close and
they didn't want.
I don't have that in me,
you know,
I don't know why,
whatever,
whatever it is.
Maybe it's because I take care of
myself.
Maybe it's genetic,
maybe it's because I live a happy life.
Basically locked pro.
I don't either.
But yeah,
I had,
I think luck is a big thing.
It's a big factor.
Um,
I have a friend who killed himself and
his brother had killed himself before
that and everybody loved him and it was
just stunning to everybody.
everybody's like,
what the fuck?
I'm,
I didn't know him that well,
but I knew him well enough to really,
like them was really,
really good guy.
And people get down.
You have to be in so much pain to do
that.
I don't know what it is.
It's a.
So you know,
a guy like tom arnold,
who knows,
he might be like,
he might've tasted the barrel a couple
of times and been like,
you know what?
I'm just going to fuck it.
Shot,
he's a got a lot of energy.
Does he?
Tom?
From what I've seen.
Yeah.
What have you seen?
I played this game with him.
It was like a big house game,
but your people and it was a just run
around and tag things.
I never quite figured it out.
He was sweating like a pig and running
around behind it.
Yeah.
I liked that show idea that I'm like,
check it out his show.
It's not out yet,
right?
I don't think so.
I think his vice.
What is,
what's going on with vice?
Somebody tell me that vice is going
away.
It's not going away.
They uh,
the changes are happening.
so they hired a new ceo or vp or
something that's sort of all the
program.
I'd probabLy be changed for the fall.
it's weird that it's a whole channel.
It's like It's a whole channel.
Vice has a channel.
I couldn't find it saved my life.
Yeah,
there's too many god damn channels.
Channels.
You know what's hilarious?
I watch a lot of hunting shows and the
outdoors shows,
they're all like a lot of like really
christiany people.
Like a lot of these hunting,
outdoors type to like to know christ,
just like,
uh,
just want to thank you lord for this
opportunity to take down this.
Like there's a lot of that.
But what's funny is that on direct tv
they're only like two or three channels
removed from hardcore porn.
So it's like you go through the lineup
you go into to get into the five
hundreds and it's hardcore porn,
hardcore porn like daddies and step
daughters and big cocks and holes.
And then right after that,
it's like the great outdoors,
you know,
and jesus and little landmines blessed
with mike,
the hunter.
I'm blessed mount here,
blessed this great world and this great
country.
Blessed
hill.
You w and they have like the.
Yeah,
they have the uh,
scientology channel now
channel.
I think it's up there.
Nice.
$500.
I did radio once.
I'll never forget this.
I did this radio show in denver and uh,
it just morning radio before gig,
like you know,
you,
do you promote the gay k joe rogan's
going to be at the comedy works in
denver here this weekend.
And then in the middle of the thing they
go,
it's time for our pledge of allegiance,
ladies and gentlemen.
And so I'm sitting there going,
what is happening?
So this is two.
They put their fucking hand on their
heart and they go,
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for which is.
And they get into it like full
earnestness and we're,
we're looking at each other,
me and uh,
I think ari or duncan was with me and
we're like,
what in the fuck did you play along?
Well I would if it was like a game or
something like that and you know,
stand for the flag.
Okay,
I'll do that.
I'm not going to make anybody feel bad.
That's not what it was.
It was a radio show.
You're in the middle of the radio show
and you do a pledge of allegiance.
So what the fuck is this?
Did you stay just stay still or.
I don't remember what I did.
No,
I remember.
I remember being high as fuck.
So it made it extra weird because
whenever I would do those radio shows,
we would just meet downstairs because
you know,
you got to be at them at 6:00
in the morning,
you're exhausted and you know,
you don't necessarily really want to do
it,
but we would meet downstairs and get
becu and so then it was an adventure.
It was like everything was free that the
wind was scaring me.
I was like,
oh,
where's the car that's taking us to get
in the car?
And then we talked to the people and it
was always like,
all right to the driver,
like,
okay,
who's the biggest dickhead you've ever
had to drive?
Because there's always like one story
comedians that hated being there and it
was always.
I would hear you would hear a bunch of
them,
but like disgruntled,
angry people.
One of them was always richard.
Jenny.
There was always at richard.
Shannon was always properly.
Yeah,
richard genuine because he never wanted
to be that guy.
He never wanted to be the road.
He wanted to be that guy who put
together the act that got them the jerry
seinfeld sitcom.
Right,
and meanwhile he was one of the greatest
standup comedians of all time.
You saw him a bunch of times when I was
coming up and a bunch of times in clubs
and he was a fucking killer,
like one of the most unheralded and
unappreciated,
underappreciated standups of all time.
He's the only one of my all time
favorites,
but.
But it was bumming me out.
I would hear that.
He was miserable.
He didn't want to talk to anybody.
It was all bummed out.
I was like,
here is like the.
His death is crawford was making
pancakes and he blew his face off.
He was still alive.
He like,
did it.
It went wrong.
Oh jesus christ.
To bring the room down.
She's so he went under the chin.
Yeah.
I guess it's slit.
That happens more often.
You just take the face.
Fuck taking the face.
Jesus christ be back.
That's another one.
Another guy killed himself.
Crazy.
That,
you know,
it's so common.
It's so common.
It's hard to be a person.
We're the first species that knows we're
going to die.
Very aware of our like impending death.
That right there.
You need to medicate that species.
If you looked at a chart,
the evolution of monkeys,
you go,
okay,
this first level of primate,
we gotta help them out.
Right.
They're dealing with so they're going to
get very religious,
which is good,
but some of them we got to medicate this
group.
Yeah.
They can handle it on their own.
Well,
we used to die young,
so it was like you wouldn't have to deal
on yourself because you only live to be
30 and now we have so much more time on
her hands.
Want have to work all day to get a meal
and then collapse.
We're sitting around and I could think
about this.
Fuck.
You see yourself getting older every day
to happening.
It's happening.
I love it.
You love aging.
What's your favorite part of the pain or
the.
I liked the pains.
I like tired.
That's tough to get some bursitis.
That's pretty sweet.
Nice.
I do like though,
I do feel more comfortable.
I'm feeling less anxious in some ways
more another.
Oh,
I guess I'm pretty.
Even though,
well,
you're more aware of things,
but then you're also going to be more
aware of your impending demise.
We don't live long enough like we need
to live 500 years.
I've thought about the first hundred
years to fix like your childhood stuff
that she imagined though.
If you did leave live 500 years,
would you be dating like 100 year old?
It'd be like these fucking 100 year olds
don't know shit.
She said she doesn't know shit.
Hadn't been around.
Do you imagine if you were 500 years old
and you were dating a 30 year old people
will be like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
You couldn't do it,
but why not?
She's a grown ass woman.
She's 30 years old.
That's a grown ass woman,
right?
Like a 30 year old could data 50 year
old,
60 year old and you're like,
you'd better be rich.
A 70 year old.
Like something that'd be going on.
Yeah.
I don't feel like we mature after 25 men
myself then.
I don't know,
but don't you think though that there is
a certain requirement of a lack of
maturity to be funny to be like,
like some of the shit that you did in
those videos?
A grownup would not,
you would not do,
you know,
like,
oh,
you hit that retarded kid,
but you have caitlyn.
Caitlyn like driving with a clean record
now because bruce killed that fucking
lady.
I mean,
which is I wonder if that's the case.
I don't know what's happening with that
case,
but the video doesn't look great.
Um,
I'm,
it's an accident obviously,
but uh,
no,
it's horrible.
That family must be like to have that
happen to them.
They lose their loved one and then to
see her just like completely around just
hero of the year and all that rich man,
ma'am
smudger now baby,
there's a show called lost in
transition,
which I recommend highlights people
transitioning and it's a lot of old
people in their fifties and stuff.
Wow.
That's what's weird about it.
It's like there's a lot of it is people
that have kind of given up on sex don't
even want to have sex anymore.
Yeah.
Which is one of the things that caitlin
said.
Sex is kind of like,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
Right.
But then why I snippety snip,
I don't know,
but the.
They say that they become like teenagers
when they do transition.
There was like a period where they're
feeling this teenage feel that coming
into their own finally,
but they're older men.
You know,
when it had this period in caitlin,
they kind of got caught it on that show
a little bit.
It's like you're kind of like a new
person,
I guess you feel like that it's timed.
I feel like this is.
You remember when we read about George
Washington having wooden teeth?
Yeah.
I read about that.
Is that not true?
Yeah.
I'm sure he did the best they had,
but I think you hear about that.
If you heard about a guy today that it
wouldn't.
The book,
what the fuck get that kind of a
dentist.
The fuck is he?
Do they have implants and give them real
teeth is crazy.
I feel like
there is going to be a time,
maybe not in our lifetimes,
but maybe shortly after where you know
they use crispr or some gene editing
materials,
something like that where they can
actually turn you into a.
Oh well,
I mean once you go through puberty.
No,
no,
no.
Can alter your jeans.
Look what what they can do now.
What mostly what they're doing now is
they're doing work with embryos and
they're,
they,
they're planning on altering people from
the jump,
like from the time they're born,
but as that technology gets better,
more effective,
they're going to be able to utilize it
on regular people and they've actually
started introducing certain genes into
people that didn't have them before in
order to fix certain ailments or
alterations in jeans to like to try to
combat certain life threatening
diseases.
Like all these things around the table
and I think it's just a matter of time
before they come up with the technology
that allows someone to completely alter
their,
their actual set.
Next.
I have things that alter by myself.
What would you check it first?
I'd be hot as fuck.
Okay.
Would you be hot in like a like nobody
likes you way.
Like,
like,
or like thor,
thor.
He came,
I was on a plane.
He came in,
he had this big for hair and he like
whipped it back.
Whoa.
And I live in,
we're like,
huh?
I was with my girlfriend at the time and
I saw her like look at me and him and
I'll take it.
yeah,
it's nothing you can do that
recalibrates like what you see as good
looking when you see actual.
Because his wife was there and she used
this model because we see your face
every year.
You're like,
I'm all right logan.
But when you see actual gorgeous people,
I was staring at them for like 20
minutes.
Real creepy.
Like,
and then I went to the bathroom and I
must've been calibrated.
I looked like a monster.
As soon as you looked
at yourself I was just like nothing.
Symmetrical lettuce on my hair look like
lettuce.
Anyway,
I,
yeah,
I would.
I'm not change any personality.
I wouldn't make myself a better person.
You wouldn't.
I would just make myself gorgeous
because that's all it matters to me.
Joe,
would you care about.
Would you be built like the rock?
I'd be ripped his shit.
Right?
I mean,
I'm pretty huge.
Right.
What kind of a giant hug would you have
on you have to take?
I'd probably like 10 inch hog.
Take four inches off my hog right now.
Will you put what you put on the table
when you hear it?
Yeah.
I had a nice,
like a.
Was that tommy who's okay.
Pushing the boat horn with his conch.
Tommy lee.
Oh yeah.
I do get a tommy genetically engineered.
Tommy leacock.
Nice.
I actually don't care about that.
I'm.
No,
I'm thinking if I had something mutated,
but right.
There's a.
There's.
There seems like a zone.
As long as you're in that zone.
You don't want to be micro penis.
You don't want to be too big that it's.
Yeah.
You don't want to hurt people.
I hate having a 12 inch cock because I
have to.
I can only get the tip in.
I get it.
It sucks.
Especially if you're the tip,
it's like a Beer can.
Yeah,
big old fat boy.
We're oN with those 500 channels right
now.
So it starts.
There's a,
there's quite a lot of those channels
still.
It's like,
don't these people know about the
internet?
Like whY are you paying 29,
99 for this?
Yeah,
whatever you're paying.
How is that not dead yet?
I,
it's probably kids that parents aren't
looking and they just rack it uP.
Or guys who just want four k in the big
screen,
have enough.
Has enough time gone by.
We've noticed the effect of online porn.
Uh,
well first your with pubic hair.
Oh,
pubic cared.
Vanished.
That's true bit my act about it.
It's like the best sign of porns
influence in our culture is the absence
of pubic hair.
Like if you had a time machine and you
can get scientists from the future and
they're studying the time period between
1990 and 2018,
the most confusing thing would be what
happened to the pubic hair because
there's no historical record.
Nobody discussed it.
Interesting.
They just started hacking off their
pubes.
How do you feel about the bald
situation?
It's normal.
It doesn't.
It doesn't bother me anymore,
but when I was a kid,
I mean when I was young,
nobody did anything.
Girls would.
It was chaos down there.
It was a disaster.
It was like he would touch their.
Like when you were going down on a girl
or you were fooling around,
you put your hand down her pants and you
feel it outside the underwear.
There was like an afro in there.
Like you had like a covering over,
like the forest buffer.
Yeah.
I was like,
somebody threw like five haircut.
Somebody threw a parachute over tree
tops.
Just touch it.
Yeah.
I mean I was
an adult when I really like I,
I thought it was just like a barbie
doll.
Like I didn't really know that there was
so much going on until a.
There was a funny moment when I was in
high school.
It was a girl that I was dating at the
time.
It was actually right after high school
and she had this guy that she had.
We had to like fooled around a bunch of
times,
like fooled around,
don't fool around for a few months,
fooled around that kind of thing and she
had some boyfriends that she was dating
for awhile and this boyfriend apparently
got her to shave her pussy and she,
well we were fooling around just like,
I can't,
I can't.
I go,
what's the matter?
She goes,
I can't show you.
I go,
you can't show me what?
And she was like,
he made me shave.
I go,
he made you shave?
She goes,
I don't want you to see.
It's so embarrassing.
I go,
I don't give a shit so you don't have
any hair down there.
I was like,
but it was weird.
That was the first time I'd ever seen
him shaped box.
Weird when you're like,
whoa,
look at all this.
It was,
it was like my beard.
It was like this.
I shaved like three days ago.
So it was like that.
Yeah.
It was like,
it was coming back,
but it was coming back and she was
italian,
so it was just chaos.
It was coming back like,
you know,
it was the whole fucking they'll put
women really.
Do I have to wax that?
You have to shave their feet.
They have to shave their legs.
They have to shave everything,
whatever.
Everything kind of hair on it.
Me to hasn't hit that area.
Well that's not what it is.
Me too is about sexual harassment and
assault.
So to be about grooming choices.
Let me too.
Shit.
I hate shaving my legs.
Me too.
Me too is.
It's so ridiculous.
I haven't been reading up on that.
Would it be to.
You just don't read like what does me
to.
Anything they're upset at feminism just
said.
Well they went with the armpits.
They try to keep the armpits.
Like girls were like keeping the armpits
with it.
You have to be super,
extremely not shaved the legs.
Yeah.
And to let your ass our just grow wild
and just got to be a reckless person.
Yeah.
You have to be careless.
You don't care.
You're renegade.
You're an outsider.
Yeah.
Crazy jungle asshole hair.
Definitely better to be a man in terms
of grooming shows 100 percent.
Yeah.
You just,
you just don't,
just to be clean.
If your wife said,
I'm not shaving anymore,
would you have the talk?
Would you say whatever you want?
I would,
um,
I'd have to figure out a way to get her
to play with wax or something like that.
Just rip it all off though.
Go lasers play a game of laser tag and
people if you imagine if they had like,
that's how they get rid of it,
right?
There's laser hair removal.
But imagine if there was like a gun.
You can just drive down the street and
shoot people's hair off.
I think that's assault those eyebrows
pop.
It seems very dangerous.
Although it's shooting a laser beam.
That's how you get lasik,
which
sounds insane to me.
Is that how they do it?
So some of it is they do with a scalpel
and actual scalpel.
Oh,
I thought they just burned her ibo,
the,
some of them.
But I think some of them they do.
I think there's two different ways to do
it.
I think sometimes they do it with an
actual scalpel,
like a blade.
And I,
I don't know if they think that that's
more precise.
I don't know what they worried about
lesbians before lasik surgery was don't
look what a fucking laser beam.
That was the whole thing.
Well here it goes.
Laser pointer,
burns hole.
And young boys are.
Oh god damn it
story going around.
It's a nine year old in Greece.
That's the actual whole burned into his
eyeball.
What the fuck?
I'm staring out with those crazy lasers
might be one of the new ones that are
coming out that like.
I know that you know,
remember they went crazy in the
nineties.
Everyone was buying red pointer lasers.
There's a new version of them that are
really high powered light stuff on fire
for pointing it out a wasn't enough.
Like people have like lit bongs on fire
with them.
They'll know if it's these crazy one is
that this same kid use.
But oh the poor isn't new.
High level.
Like people were making youtube videos
with them.
What the fuck do you do with design?
No.
Does he just have a hole in it forever?
It says decreased vision.
So just as a whole one his vision
forever.
Yeah,
I guess he's all right.
Doctors found a large macular hole in
the retina is left on the child reported
playing with the green laser pointer,
a pdd gazing into the laser beam there.
Right?
Because of the large size of the hole.
The doctors decided on a conservative
approach rather than surgery.
Fuck.
And you're fucking your eyeballs up when
you're a little kid because some asshole
parent wants to just play with their
phone and let that kid shoot laser beams
the laser.
Okay.
Wait.
Who's watching the kid?
How do you get the laser?
Did he have a job?
Did he go to the store and buy?
What the fuck are you doing with your
kid?
You got kids?
Yeah,
that scares me.
You got to make sure that you know safe.
Yeah,
we do.
Well,
you're 47 if you want to do it.
You've got to do it soon.
I got like 30 years.
Oh,
two figure this out.
Well,
trump had won when he was 60.
Okay.
Baron.
He had one who's like 60,
right?
Yeah.
So got I go back and forth.
I don't hear good reviews.
They never.
It's never like a clean do it.
It's great.
It's always champion.
Get ready.
We're gonna.
Change your life.
You've got to get ready for.
Do you have a steady gallo sleep?
Uh,
yeah.
How long?
Year and a half.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
Does she want them?
How old is she?
20.
She'll be 28 and august.
Nice.
Yeah.
I know it's young,
but I move.
She pursued me.
Just get that atar.
Keep talking.
Should we go out to go down on channel
five?
Ninety two?
I feel like such sweating.
Well,
she wants to have kids.
She's still young and fertile.
You'd probably shoot a live one in there
and make a person.
Is that the technical term one?
If you go to a doctor,
that's how I describe it.
Yeah.
Cow live round in there.
Eight like this.
Thanks doc.
I'm to show you.
You keep her legs up in the air.
You want to make sure you get it down
there.
She rides on your swimmers might not
making up the canal.
You know what I'm saying?
Is that a true thing you gotta lay him
back?
I don't know.
It makes sense.
I'd like to have kids.
I would someday.
Someday I did.
You don'T have some day when you're 47,
you really don't have some day because
one of the things about autism is a lot
of it is age of the father.
It's not just the age of the mother is
the age of the father.
I feel like I've been in a coma,
you know,
disease where you fall asleep for 20
years and you wake up.
That's how I feel.
Why?
I don't know.
I don't know where those years went.
I feel like I woke up recently and I'm
like,
well how am I.
What am I doing now?
Do you think this is because you weren't
doing what you wanted to do because you
were just doing a bunch of other shit
and the years just kept piling up maybe.
I mean,
do you feel.
I guess maybe kids you can track your
life a little easier.
Maybe it's because I didn't have kids.
It sort of seems like one chunk that
went by fast.
The kids,
you caN mark years with your kids.
Well,
the reality of being a person is if we
really do live to be 80,
9,100,
if you're really lucky that if you have
$100 it goes quick.
You buy a sandwich by some,
a drink,
get some chips and you go to the movies
and then you don't have enough for
dinner.
You know,
it's like a dollar here,
a dollar there.
You're a year is not that long.
It's 365 days it happened so quick and
next thing you know,
it's two years and then it's five years
and then 10 years later and then 30
years later and then.
Then.
Yeah.
Oh you got to get your hip replaced.
Huh?
Whoa.
What are you going to do?
You're saying I got get my,
my,
my shit in order.
That's like,
that's you're telling me right here.
You're giving me.
I think you've already done.
You're getting your shit in order,
right?
I mean,
I think,
um,
I think what you did with starting this
instagram page,
like deciding that you can't keep this
gig anymore.
It was a very brave and smart.
I realized it.
I appreciate that.
I don't feel like it's brave.
I feel like I was like that fear and not
be able to sleep and I was forced.
That's how it feels.
Well,
it's probably whatever the fuck it is,
your body,
the fate of the universe,
whatever it is just telling you like
you're not,
you can't do this anymore.
You can't,
you know,
and you just listened to it.
Some people don't ever listen man.
They just start medicating themselves.
Yeah.
And they just drone out.
They take ssri eyes and they just show
up and they just,
they just get everything becomes like a
dull medium and then just keep doing it
over and over and over again.
Yeah.
I am glad I feel right now.
Really thankful
and I'm mean just to have been able to
do shows.
People coming out.
It's just,
you know,
for years it was like up and down all
over the place.
Now I feel like I do have some kind of
following that I can directly contact.
No,
you definitely do.
And it's gonna keep growing.
I mean,
you keep putting out the videos like
you're putting out,
you're going to keep growing.
There's no way around it.
It's,
it's great.
It's fucking.
Look,
we have so many different avenues now
that didn't exist before and one of the
things that I think is really cool about
today versus when I started,
uh,
I started in 88,
is that there's,
there's not like a competitiveness with
comedians.
Instead.
There's like a hyper supportiveness.
Everybody's quick to tell you about
people who are really good.
Everybody wants everybody to know this.
LIke there's no famine anymore because I
think before when there was only one
tonight show or a letterman and there
was a sitcom and everybody was
scrambling for,
you want to get thursday night at 8:00
on nbc.
That's where the friends pot is like
everybody wanted to get in the right
spot and you know,
there's not that anymore.
That's an interesting point.
I hadn't thought of that.
Yeah.
Now it's like everybody has a youtube
channel or a twitter page or an
instagram thing or a podcast.
They're all doing their own thing and
instead of being competitive with other
comedians,
everybody's like,
everybody has everybody on there shows
like,
like all these guys that are top
podcasters,
we all do.
Everybody's show.
Yeah.
I'm always doing either joe,
he does my show or I'll do his show or
I'll do tom show or he'll do my show or
I'll do dunkin show or he'll do my.
It's like constant back and forth and
everybody's supportive because it's,
it doesn't hurt anybody.
It just helps.
And the more like if I,
if I tell people you gotta check out
kyle done against instagram page,
they're going to go and they're gonna
say he's right.
Larry's.
So it's good for everybody.
It's good for me because they know that
I'm not going to bullshit them and it's
good for anybody else to.
And it's also good because it's good for
me because I want you to do really great
because I want more of those funny
videos to watch.
It's like it's good for everybody.
I feel like giving a cash.
Ah,
luckily just keep,
uh,
keep taking dives and pool that I was
trying really hard.
It's a hard game.
It's been a while since I played.
That's my.
It's one of those games you,
you're not supposed to take time off of
that fucking stupid game.
That's a game that you have to play
every day.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll play again.
Play in a year.
Okay.
Practice practice up.
Maybe after tHe show you'll play better
because you'll be thinking,
but what you did wroNg.
No,
I definitely,
yeah.
was a rustY there.
Do you have like an ultimate goal which
you want to do with pool with stand up?
My pool goes your career now.
Now that you've got momentum,
I would,
I mean I'd love to just build the
audience,
um,
and just do a bigger venues so I don't
have to travel so much.
I'd like to just have like a life and be
able to do like weekend gigs and then
come back.
Yeah.
And have enough money to be comfortable.
Those thursday,
wednesday,
thursday,
friday,
saturday,
sunday weeks and a lot of people do.
People don't realize you're alone for 23
hours.
Then you have too much attention for an
hour,
then you're alone for 23 hours.
Go to it,
just,
yeah,
if you're not using the right,
I'm like mindset to go out and do stuff
and go to the gym.
If you're like a hurt you hermit,
you're in real trouble mentally in a lot
of people do.
I think that's what richard jenny did.
Yeah.
Um,
a lot of people do wind up hermiting
yeah.
I always make sure that I exercise and
always make sure I do something.
Go out,
do something.
It makes a giant difference.
Yeah.
You just feel way better.
I feel like a person route.
I need a routine without having a boss
or like a job.
I need a routine to stay.
When you go on the road,
do you bring somebody with you?
Like an opening act can't really afford
at this point.
That's another thing.
like,
uh,
let me get a bigger audience.
You can bring friends right now.
I just,
uh,
I jogged there.
I ride my bike there by myself.
Do you have a basket where you put all
your stuff?
Front bag.
Little thing ling,
I um,
I started bringing people on the road a
long time ago because I had a couple of
gigs that I did and the local guys were
so terrible and it was,
it made it so much more excruciating.
Oh,
absolutely.
Because you've got to sit through this
thing about watching someone who just
has no idea what the fuck they're doing.
Udl And after it's over,
you're convinced.
Nothing's funny.
There's nothing funny.
Yeah.
You hate stand up as a genre.
Like he can't be funny.
Nothing can be funny.
This isn't funny.
Nothing is funny.
It's not funny.
I had a great middle guy luckily in the
last thing they did.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
where were you?
Um,
the american comedy.
Oh,
san diego?
Yes.
Great.
What's funny audience?
So fun.
little area to write the drunks.
Awesome.
Yeah.
if you look for gals,
perhaps a little liquored up,
that's your,
that's free is a good place for you.
I love san diego period.
Lived down There.
That gets voted the number one city to
live in.
It's a fucking great place because it's
like a city,
but it's not too big and it has a little
bit of traffic,
but it's not crazy.
Perfect weather if you want to.
Yeah,
and it has everything.
It's got restaurants.
People are cool.
Also the militaries there.
It's never going to get attacked.
Well maybe it is.
I mean pearl harbor.
That's right.
It's great.
Cocaine.
You get greek cocaine.
Sure.
Oh,
fIll.
That guy's an asshole.
I gotta try.
I gotta try psychedelics because I've
never done them.
But you smoke pot,
smoke pot.
I eat it at night.
Helps me sleep.
Do you ever tried those sprays like
jumbo breast sprays,
numb marijuana sprays.
Wish I knew I brought so I would have
brought some for you.
So way to go.
You try.
Are you going to get free sprays now
because you mentioned it not by him.
Do you ever do that?
I would do that.
Like,
boy I love,
you know,
reebok's sneakers and then it's easier
to just buy them.
People send you stuff too much stuff.
I don't want.
It's like the,
you know,
you,
you probably want them just to send that
to like a homeless person or something.
Well,
I just don't want them to send it to me.
Yeah,
you know,
we can work out a thing where you give
it to me and then don't worry about it.
And then you just have like fucking
kanye west 100 like monster drink cases
he's holding.
It just ain't conspicuously as he talks.
Oh,
that's what I could do.
monetize product placement.
I'm going to monetize.
I'd like to like keep it.
I mean they were joking,
but like have caitlin just drinking
monster drinks are fantastic.
They give me energy ever since I shot my
natural,
what I went and chop off age.
I wonder if that does happen.
It happened to my dog.
I got them fix and he became very
listless.
Ooh.
Oh really?
He was like,
what's the point?
Oh no,
what's the point,
man?
Hold your dog while he was at the time.
He was five when I got his,
uh,
his gun.
Lowell schnipper snippy.
I got a tiny dog,
which isn't a great look for a man,
but what kind of dog love it?
Uh,
it's a pug chihuahua mix.
But the way I talked to my dog an excuse
it,
it's offensive to me as a man.
Like I tell myself,
I get my permission,
like window was looking at her paws and
this just came out of me.
I went,
are you looking at stinks that came out?
I'm a grown man that just,
I didn't get.
I didn't say like,
oh,
let me ask her if she's licking her
stinkies.
I just went,
why steam?
I don't know.
It wasn't even stinky.
It was like pinkies.
I was like,
geez,
have you called keys before?
Now it just came at me,
but then I was like,
maybe this is me.
I'm alone with my dog.
Like maybe I packed like this.
Like maybe this is my truth.
I have a dog that's about to die.
Sorry.
I have one of my,
one of my dogs is 13.
He's a massive and he's really bad.
He can't walk anymore.
And it takes like for him to come in to
eat.
It takes several minutes,
several minutes of him walking,
you know,
five,
six yards.
It's like we adopt these terminally ill
children because you get attached to
them like kids and you wouldn't adopt a
kid.
Is gonna die at 14?
Well,
I have him and I have another dog is
also very old.
Who's a shibu.
He knew english max.
He's a little
bit better,
but he's,
he's not gonna make it or either don't
have a long.
He's got real problems walking as well.
But then I have marshall who's a year
and six months and he's a golden
retriever,
is the total opposite.
He just fucking leaps into the pool and
it runs around the pool and circles and
he goes running with me and the hills
and he's a fuckIng.
Just a ball of energy and love and
happiness and you just get to see him at
this stage.
And I'm like,
damn,
one day marshall's going to be 13.
I'm going to see marshall.
Like these dogs.
It's gonna.
It's gonna be a,
just a giant struggle.
So it's hard to really hard.
I've been fucking hard man.
I don't know.
Uh,
it looks like to have kids,
but I feel like very,
I get really attached to me.
My dogs.
Yeah.
It's that times a million with kids.
It's that times 2 million.
One of the things that changed with me
is,
uh,
the way I look at people because I
always considered people just,
you know,
I meet you,
you're 47.
I just,
well kyle's 47.
It's what he is,
but I don't,
I didn't know you when you were two,
you know,
and now when I meet people and I meet
people,
like I meet some old asshole all like
that old dickhead,
he's a little baby.
Oh,
he was a baby and he became this old
dickhead.
Like how did this happen?
Like what,
what went wrong?
And I'm so much more compassionate.
I'm so much more.
I care about people so much more.
And I care about,
I think I give them more of a break.
I give people way more of a board and I
noticed this is something that I don't
see as much in single guys who don't
have children.
Yeah,
you don't,
you know,
like there's something about it that the
world is dog eat dog,
you're competing for your career,
you're competing for love interests,
you're competing for this and that and
everybody's like,
fuck that guy.
Fuck him.
And everybody's trying to get nobody's.
Nobody looks at people and go,
oh,
that could have been my son.
Yeah,
that's a little baby that became this
weirdo 28 year old man.
That's one thing I hear about having
kids.
That is very attractive to me that it
does shift your perspective and
massively as whole new,
massively.
11 life changed who I am,
changed who I am and it just it and
permanently.
You scare me about that autistic thing
though.
Really?
Well,
it's real.
You know,
there's a correlation.
There's a correlation between older men
and higher incidences of autism.
You get the percentages,
you got some statistics here for you.
Great.
I mean,
look,
a lot of people do it and they're fine
and it's going to help for sure that
your gals a young,
she's not even 30.
Yeah.
Shoot,
shoot live one done there.
One right down the old tube.
Red get,
just get to two years,
get to two years.
You guys have been together a year and a
half.
Yeah.
Make it to two years almost.
Years when to remove
the goalie.
Oh shoot.
Pucks,
bam,
bam.
Bam.
From the free throw line and yeah,
it seems like an important life
experience.
I did have.
It is in.
It's not for everybody.
And one of the things that used to drive
me crazy when I was single is people
would say,
uh,
you know,
you have to have kids.
You don't have kids.
You don't live in a normal life.
That's crazy.
That's so stupId that,
that is such a,
like the idea that you can't be a
complete human being unless you
recreate,
recreate a word I'm looking for
reproduced.
Why?
How come that where it wouldn't come
out.
It's not that far off though.
Recreated.
A mother may.
Well,
why wasn't reproduced like right there.
I was having trouble with a anecdote,
the antidote anecdote,
but there's a super close but the,
that you can be a fucking completely
fulfilled person and never get married
and never have a kid.
You just have to have good friends and
enjoy what you do.
There's nothing wrong with that
phrasing.
Yeah,
it's a little what I just remember being
a kid and like my uncle like wasn't
married or had kids.
I was always like,
what's up with them?
Smart.
That guy partying,
going to bill maher route.
Do you?
But without getting me into the alarm.
Do you have a bill maher character?
Right?
You do.
I saw you did it.
You went to those people who thinks she
wouldn't have those people.
You're not okay.
You're wrong.
There is no god.
Okay.
It's very like,
I know everything I do agree with a lot
of.
He says,
yeah,
he's a smart guy.
That shows a weird show.
Everybody talking over each other.
five people on panel,
whatever it is for you over the phone.
So many People.
Do you see the uh,
ben aflac one?
Yes.
With sam harris.
Sam is a friend who loves sam.
I love sam to.
That was hilarious.
I think ben,
I think ben affleck was roided up right?
I really had that energy,
but he also was like kind of red and
thick.
Neck was thick,
like,
listen,
when you're 40,
whatever the fuck he is and you want to
Pack on that kind of muscles.
It was only one way.
You gotta fucking take that plunger.
Oops.
Shoot.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
I think he was juiced up and I think he
just was hyper aggressive virtue
signaling and really didn't even know
what the fuck he was talking about and
clearly picked the wrong guy.
Oh my god.
I would never argue with sam harris.
I think about it.
I think like the fact that he can't be
president really pisses me off.
Like why can't I want a guy who's
smarter than me?
Well,
he could be president.
I don't think being an atheist.
Maybe not.
Yeah.
It's like,
why did I get.
I don't get this whole thing of like,
I want to.
I don't want to vote for this guy.
I can relate to him.
He's like,
mate,
I don't want a guy like me.
It's like when a babysitter like I want
to babysit.
I want someone who's superior exactly.
Smarter,
come in.
He's very meditative.
Sam and mom and I firmly believe no one
should be president.
I think there should be a council.
Oh,
wise people.
I love that idea.
Like the jedi council fucking eight
people or something.
Just really,
really smart people that have no idea
and I think they should all have had to
do mushrooms.
All of them I think about that have to
do psychedelic experiences.
All of them.
They should be high.
Can it not do mushrooms while they're on
the job,
but have in the past where they
understand there's more to life than
this thing.
That's part of the platform.
The person needs to be like,
I did try mushrooms,
didn't know you gotta go deep.
You've got to take the heroic dose.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'd love that idea.
Like a little think tank.
Yeah.
Eight people,
super wise people.
I don't really think the mushroom thing
is necessary but,
but consider it wise,
objective people that care and have a
deep,
a deep sense of responsibility to sort
of guide our country and the best way
possible.
I probably done for their own interests.
Exactly.
I put neil degrasse tyson on this.
Well,
you'd be great for some sort of a role
as a science educator and the government
anyway.
It's just some old.
He.
What?
What's great about neil is he's one of
the first guys in our lifetime that made
science fun,
made,
made astrophysics interest so
enthusiastic.
He's a great guy.
I fucking love it.
If we have aliens,
like we got to send one guy.
Oh,
he's the guy elliot said neil degrasse
tyson.
Well,
he's also even,
even though like he'll be talking to
someone who is,
you know,
just doesn't really understand what he's
saying.
He's not an elitist exactly the way he
argues.
He's caring about guiding him and he's a
master at it.
He's a really likable guy,
but he is like that all the time.
Like he's like that when the camera's
off.
He's just a great guy and one quality
has.
It.
Rarely does someone who's like really
smart habits.
He's a big laffer.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like no.
Her acumen,
fun guy,
you know,
he used to be a wrestler talking about
mushrooms.
He used to be a wrestler.
Really?
Hey,
wrestled in high school.
He was like that.
I think he wrestled in college too.
He was jacked,
like fucking jacked.
He's an all around a quality human.
Yes.
Sam harris to the way he argues,
just stays calm.
Well,
he doesn't argue about things he doesn't
understand either.
You know,
like if sam has a conversation and uh,
say like he's
having a conversation with someone about
whatever the fuck it is.
Some,
some discipline that's outside of his
realm.
And then,
you know,
he'll,
he'll ask questions like he doesn't
have,
he's not,
he's not a know it all.
That's how you learn,
will forget.
But if he's talking to you about
something and he's arguing,
it's because he understands what he's
talking about.
But that's a rare quality man.
There's so many people that want to
argue about shit that they really don't
even understand.
You know?
And I don't think there's anything wrong
with discussing things that you really
don't understand to try to understand
them,
especially if you're doing it in a
casual conversation or even a podcast.
But there's a lot of fucking people that
argue shit and they're just trying to
win,
you know,
they're just trying to score points.
They're not really talking right.
He got a lot of that,
right.
I do it a lot,
but I'm more aware of it.
Watching people who were,
who don't do it.
You learned a pizza,
normal tHing.
You get caught up in your idea and then
you want your idea to be right.
Yeah.
And then you kinda like chase down all
the evidence that would show that your
ideas,
riGht?
You see this all the time when someone
gets accused of something and we don't
know exactly what happened.
DO you see these groups of people that
automatically want to think that person
is guilty and automatically have a
preconceived idea of what went down,
how it went down,
regardless of what the other person
said.
Like they only want to look at it one
way.
Just gets weird,
real weird with people harder now to all
the information you have to be,
have to be a little more.
Um,
you know,
what,
hashtag fake news.
Hashtag,
hashtag.
I'll come back,
I'll get smarter.
And come back,
what kind of smart you're going to get.
Book smart.
I get sam harris,
neil degrasse tYson smart.
If I gave you a pill and the pill would
make you super smart but you wouldn't be
fun anymore,
would you take it?
What would I be happy?
Those are the same.
No one can decide whether or not you're
going to be happy,
but you.
What am I going to do it again?
That's up to you again.
I don't think I would take,
I think do torture and said,
hey,
would you stay stupid?
HalF retarded and funny.
Very little oxygen.
When I was born was Purple and they were
like,
this one might come out a little goofy
and we have to wait and see if he starts
talking and then I started talking like,
oh,
he's all right really?
But I have a theory that like I was born
a genius,
got a little retarded.
I'm like kind of normal.
It's just a theory.
But my genius came up with it not be a
bad theory mean what a roll of the dice,
whether you're,
you're born super smart or not.
So roll the dice.
Oh,
some people that just have better
brains.
Yeah.
There's some people that are just really
good at math.
Like I used to have to a friend,
my friend johnny.
You could just yell out math problems to
them.
Yeah.
Like five times five minus six divided
by seven multiplied by 100 divided by
three and he would go 16.
You'd be like,
what the fuck?
And like someone would be sitting next
to him with a calculator
and they would like try to keep up.
He could do it as fast as someone can
type it in with a calculator.
Yeah.
It was bizarre and useless talents.
Talents have calculators.
Asshole.
Born 200 years ago.
Batteries are everywhere.
So batteries.
We need you.
Yeah.
That's a calculator on my phone.
My phone as a calculator.
Not to bring up sam harris again.
But that whole like,
um,
you know,
freewill book,
um,
you know,
that kinda.
That's a mind.
Fuck.
That's.
It really is because your mind doesn't
want to believe that.
It's just not.
It's like not believing in heaven.
You want to believe that it's hard to.
It's just hard.
But there's definitely so much luck
involved in who your parents were,
how you were raised life experiences,
for sure.
You know,
whether or not you've ever been attacked
or assaulted,
robbed a,
whether you've been in an accident or
you got gravely injured.
There's so many variables that are just
fortunate.
Just luck.
Yeah.
There's so many.
It'd be just someone danced with.
Mom was wedding.
Whatever.
Yeah.
There's,
there's so many things that you just
fucking luck.
Well look,
we're all lucky we're here.
We weren't born in the jungles of
Guatemala or somewhere.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We're just lucky me.
You're,
you're,
you want a huge one in a trillion
lottery to be born.
Yeah.
And then to be born in the us at this
time that we have air conditioning and
gps.
Why don't we revere science more that if
there's a god,
he's saying,
I'm rewarding you every time you listen
to science.
And yet so much of religion is like a
against science.
I don't know.
Look,
I don't think science is a saying,
hey,
nobody comes back from the dead after
three days.
Hey,
people can't really walk on water.
uh,
why did he turn water into wine?
Why don't he just make wine?
He's fucking magic.
I never thought of that.
Stop with the magic trick,
bro.
We try to get fucked up.
Just make us tired of wine.
Got any whiskey in that.
Those magic robes get the miracles of
worst,
sort of like they're fucking parlor
tricks.
His miracles are horrible.
You know,
it was the best.
There was a thing back in the eighties
called the power team for jesus and what
they were with these dudes that would do
like feats of strength for jesus.
Like they would,
uh,
they would fucking break bricks with
their head.
They would rip phone books and half they
would lift up heavy weights.
Do it for jesus.
Wow.
That jesus gave him the power.
Yeah.
But it was also like,
hey dude,
jesus,
he's magic.
He's got magic.
Like he's not going to be impressed by
you breaking a board with your extra
thick skull.
You fucking wow.
Look at one of my children down there.
Have you never heard of them?
No,
I dude,
I used to watch them all the time.
They were all like this religious
channel and I used to watch the power
team for jesus going,
what in the fuck is this?
That's amazing.
It was so How have you found anything on
it?
I found a good one to just.
Those guYs are the third street
promenade team for genius.
Jesus.
Yeah.
See
iT braked brick this brick for the load
for sure.
they're called devil.
oh,
my head.
Oh yeah,
he kicked it.
Oh,
whoa.
It seems a little too easy to break.
Those were really making a mess for
jesus.
Literally drops it.
Elbow download.
I'm going to blow up this balloon and
blow it up until it explodes.
That's why they have to wear goggles on,
but yeah,
it's a bladder.
That's not.
This trick is not great.
oh wow.
Actually,
right in the face.
Stupid song.
Boom.
Here comes the boom.
I ripped a phone,
but what's that?
Was that.
I thought it was pod.
That's saliva pod as a christian rock
band.
Pod.
Payable on death was the goal of
christian rock.
Yeah.
That's like,
um.
They have some great fucking song.
Here comes the boom.
Yeah.
It's brooke's ripping up phone books in
half for jesus.
Look at this.
It's bended a bar for jesus is going to
love this,
and by the way,
this is a.
This is a newer power team.
This is not the original power team.
Power came two point zero.
Oh,
is it?
Well,
the older guys are dead from steroids.
1990 jesus.
Now this is a 1991.
Yeah.
This huddle look at is.
Look at the fuCking mall at bro.
Shaved armpits by the way.
notice that,
right?
That just loves to look at the pants.
Those puffy pants,
those gym pants.
Hold on.
What's he saying?
Oh my friends were inside the door.
Shut behind me.
Where's your video,
bro?
Door shut.
Jesus took the blinders,
enrolled them right off my eyes and
inside of that bar for the first time in
my life,
I saw the world for what it really had
to offer me he wanted.
It was a big fat zero.
I got in my car.
I drove home with my wife.
We got inside our apartment.
My wife went and sat on the couch,
hiGh paced back and forth in the living
room,
chain down everything to world pass by
him and I was chained down.
I've looked all my life and body for
people were put pro wrestling's a little
tube
without the other guy.
For people who think progressing is too
complicated,
like I don't get what they're saying.
And pro wrestling.
There's too many people.
Too many moving pieces.
It hurts my brain.
I like this.
Yeah.
That was a huge crowd.
Dude.
That's like 20 plus thousand people.
It plays a giant.
Oh,
I'm the wrong business.
Yeah.
Look,
they lift things up for,
for the lord.
Oh,
what happened?
The mallet,
bro.
Get the fuck is.
He didn't jump rope.
Looks bigger to.
He did more roids and got rid of his
head.
Grew his foreheads larger.
MultIple per.
They're going to throw him into a pit or
something.
This is crazy.
Oh,
I wonder if it has the same speech or if
he gives a different one every time.
Oh,
that's the same guy bro.
Molokais right behind them.
Now he's got the chains on there.
The same human.
Yeah,
the same guy that it's a clone tag team
partner.
Maybe they're twins.
They're tag team partners.
Oh,
christ.
Ladies and gentlemen,
are you committed to god?
The more you'll be committed to each
other,
you'll never understand commitment.
The first time I ever saw them was jerry
springer or something.
They had a smash put jesus on jerry
springer.
Sometimes.
You know,
they had to find out who's the baby?
Maury maury was.
Who's the baby daddy?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Here's your baby daddy.
Huh?
Has anybody contacted you from them?
The kardashians?
No.
What would you do and everything slid
into your dmz.
you saw dm and was kanye and you see the
blue check mark.
You're like,
oh jesus christ.
I would sNap a photo and I'm tired.
I'm tired of caitlin to be on my side
quarter.
Yeah,
I would love that.
Would you obviously a.
no.
I mean I feel like.
Would they be mad?
I don't think they'd be mad.
Whenever I do a comedy sPecial,
one of the things that I do is I have a
moment of panic after I'm done.
Oh,
what a calls.
I smoked pot and I get super paranoid
and I go,
oh,
I shouldn't have done that.
But I mean in the last one was my
caitlyn jenner bit.
I by the way,
love that.
When I saw this,
how,
you know,
it's a good day.
I was like,
ah,
I wish I'd thought of that now.
And you'll,
oh yeah,
that's the angle.
But it was,
well I,
I came,
I had to think for so long how to do
that and the way to it was just to shit
on myself first and then also have a lot
of truth in it about how like I've never
been happier,
but I'm,
I've never been more of a bitch.
I live in a house filled With girls.
There was all women in my house.
I don't,
I have zero say in like where things go
or what color things are.
It's all,
it's easier to,
to just let them run out.
I want them to be happy and I don't need
my masculine energy everywhere.
And that's also one of the nice things
about this place.
This place is clearly like a big oldest
is a bro,
bro.
It's a fucking bro warehouse.
But um,
so I've,
I've felt like,
oh,
that's the thing because they're turning
me softer for sure.
Like women living with all these women
and I've changed the way I communicate
and think and behave.
I'm turning into a bitch.
I'm like,
I've never been more of a bitch in my
life.
And so the idea was like if my,
my manhood was a mountain of marbles,
like every day they take just like,
what's the big deal?
You have So many marbles,
god,
dad,
why do you care?
Why do you even care?
And then I'm,
I'm like,
I'm seeing where this is going.
And then I,
then I said,
okay,
this is what it is.
That's where the bit is.
The bit is I'm not going out like bruce
jenner.
And then unlike like,
everybody's like,
he's always been a woman,
like maybe,
maybe,
or maybe if you live with crazy bitches
long enough,
you fucking become one.
Like kanye.
You don't like what you're saying.
I don't like what I'm saying.
He's going crazy.
He's clearly going crazy.
You live with crazy people.
It's entirely so that bit was one of the
ones where after I released it like,
oh,
that poor girl,
she doesn't need me to be pretending
that she gets reduced by demons in the
middle of the night while she's
sleeping.
BuT it was so fun to do.
It was also a fucked up it to do because
in order to do it I literally had to
think like a demon.
Like I would,
I would think like I was trying to
seduce her.
It goes,
it goes like whispered in her ear,
like a demon.
Like wow,
there's no effect on the one of us.
You can just do that.
Yeah,
that's really hard.
Can I can't be one of you?
What was born a man?
You see the license old,
like a footage of the old kardashians
shows and bruce will come in like,
yo girls and you're a makeup test off.
ApparentlY all he was cross dressing
that whole time.
Yeah.
Since he was younger.
You know what the,
there's a theory by one of the guys who
was In the olympics with them that,
uh,
you know,
they had,
everybody was writing it up back then.
Everybody,
I mean they just,
they just gave everybody steroids.
And one of the things that happens to
men when they take large doses of
steroids is that your testosterone shuts
down.
Your body just shuts down.
Oh yeah.
And there's a real.
there's a depression period.
There's a lot of weird things that
happen to men.
One of the other things that happens is
your body starts producing way more
estrogen.
You get something called bitch tits.
Oh,
I received that dose.
Got no,
it's different.
It's called gynecoMastia and
gynecomastia comes from in introducing
too much exogenous testosterone into
your system.
Your body starts producing estrogen to
sort of balance it out.
And in that process you grow tits
literally.
Yeah.
So what this person from the.
I don't remember if they named the
person who it was,
but they were saying that all of this
happened right when bruce got off
steroids,
like right after the olympics,
like you saw these,
this transition taking place where he
was just baffled and confused.
I heard that when he was a kid,
he used to steal his mom's or his
sister's clothes or something like that.
I heard,
I don't know my brain.
That makes sense.
That makes more sense.
Me,
I don't like these.
She's tortured and that must be awful.
I really like really feel comfortable
like making.
I don't make fun of like her ed taylor
or something like she's really a
ridiculous person.
Like besides the forgetting the
transgender thing,
like she's really funny.
Well,
how about the fucking killed the lady
and never bring it up.
Just that alone that yeah,
that is a.
I mean all of the conversations
afterwards,
all the interviews afterwards,
it wasn't this existential crisis of
having accidentally killed someone and
being at this point in your life where
you're like,
oh my god,
I don't have much time to live,
and I just sent some woman to her grave
because I wasn't paying attention at the
wheel.
My escalate.
That never got brought up.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't know like what she felt behind
closed doors,
but it didn't seem like it slowed her
down.
I think I'd take a month off and be
like,
I got to like not be out in public and I
feel horrible and I'm going to take care
of this for a different eye.
Shades care.
She wants to even famous.
I didn't know how that cracked out and
talk about that.
You're so good at that impression.
You could do her onstage and you don't
even need like the face swap,
like people would just start laughing
do and I did at largo.
I got fully dressed up and I put like
glasses on it back and introduce you as
caitlyn jenner.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I came out as like it was a big risk and
zach galifianakis is backstage.
I'm like,
I don't know what was going to go,
and he was like,
I've done.
I've dressed up as woman.
Then I'll just say this.
It's a longer fall when it fails,
which is true,
like if you get all dressed up and you
bomb,
it's like
dark scared me.
Darkness,
darkness.
Lucky that she's ridiculous enough that
you could point things out.
Like this is one of the things that
people always say about you don't want.
When people were clamoring about what a
great person hillary clinton was,
I'm like,
do you know that she didn't endorse gay
marriage until 2013?
She was against know that against gay
marriage until 2013.
She's a fucking ridiculous person.
There's hundreds of videos of her lying
here.
What she said,
and you hear what the truth is right
here.
Like the comey investigation with the
fbi found that deleted emails.
Ben gazi,
she says,
just not an honest person.
Maybe that's part of the job.
I don't know,
but that,
that if you bring that up to people,
they have less of an argument.
well,
with caitlin,
I'll bring up the fact that she's
against gay marriage and people go,
wait,
what?
No.
Are you serious?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
Here I'm going to play something.
And then you play.
You're saying,
wow,
I'm but traditional girl.
Yeah.
It really is.
So mind blowing that it went over.
You almost can't.
I can't even wrap my head around.
That's got to be a joke.
I can't
can that much.
They seem to be like letting that slide,
but they don't see how fucking
ridiculous that is.
Very hypocritical.
Just crazy.
it's crazy is what it is.
It's like mentally unstable.
There's,
there's bad processing going on,
abs.
I mean there's no sense or or empathy to
put that on this screen right there.
You.
It's crazy.
First of all,
the.
The thing about gay marriage to me has
always been who gives a fuck,
right?
Are we pretending that they don't love
each other?
Like what are we doing?
Are we pretending that it's immoral?
Okay,
well,
it's a moral thing.
Then we have a real argument,
right,
like what is morality?
If it's not two people that love each
other,
you have a problem with the fact that
they're both boys.
They've done scientific studies that
have shown that there's different.
They have a different pattern to the way
their brain thinks.
Yeah,
I mean they can show the difference in
the way,
especially with trans kids and trans
people there.
There are showing with mris and all
these different ways of measuring,
like their brains appear to work more
like a woman's brain and they do like a
man's brain.
Like there's,
there's something going on.
It's not as simple as delusions and then
with gay people there's clearly
something going on where they're
attracted only to the same sex.
It's like a biological issue and this
issue is it exists.
So to pretend that they're supposed to
ignore that for your benefit.
Right.
Todd,
you know todd glass?
Sure.
You brought up a great are insightful
thing because he lived a lot.
People didn't know he was gay,
so he heard guys talking or people who
are like homophobic or whatever and his
point of view is like he thinks a lot of
the.
A lot of this is from people imagine the
act and they're grossed out.
It really bothers them and he was
saying,
do you want to imagine your sister
giving a blow job?
No,
it's disgusting,
but you want her to feel loved and you
want her to have that happiness and
that's all he was asking for.
I thought that was insightful thing.
I think a lot of times too,
it's just lack of exposure to gay people
when you're young in particular,
you know,
being or having them be accepted by your
family and other people and like what if
you were around?
When I was a kid,
I got really lucky.
I lived in san francisco from the time I
was seven to 11 and we were on a lot of
gay people.
My next door neighborS were gay and they
would get naked with my aunt and it
would play the bongos.
They would smoke pot,
play the bongos because it was san
francisco or in the seventies.
Yeah,
so to me gay people were just like,
it was a normal thing.
It was just,
this guy is gay,
this guy is black,
this guy is old disco.
It's just a person.
Just different kind of person.
And then I moved to Florida.
Well when we were,
when I was 11,
we moved to Florida.
We moved to gains,
basically moved to a different country.
I moved to planet stupid and these
people that I lived,
I had my friend,
his name was candy candido and he was a
cuban kid and his dad was fucking super
homophobic and so I remember I went over
his house,
wants after school to play and his dad
was like,
I can't believe these fucking faggots
want to get married,
believe
this shit.
And he's throwing the newspaper down on
a table.
And I remember I was,
I was 11.
I was like,
what's wrong with this fucking dummy?
Why does he care?
Like,
why is this bothering him at all?
It didn't even make sense to me.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people real rage
underneath it all,
which I think they're scared of being
gay and I don't want anybody to think
they're gay.
They just,
it's just just putting it off and it may
be like the act.
Discuss them like the all sex is
disgusting and the all of it.
You're doing it wrong.
Oh,
I am.
Yeah.
I'll talk to you after the show after
show and give me some pointers.
Something was.
Maybe that's why you haven't had a kid
yet.
Thirty years.
I've been trying put it in the bud like
you're supposed to.
No,
no,
don't do that.
How long have we been talking about?
I feel like I've been talking two hours.
Forty minutes.
Somewhere around there.
We're going to wrap it up.
I'm a gabber huh?
No,
we always do this.
Oh wait,
what is a normal length of a show?
Probably around that.
Really?
Yeah.
You do this twice a week.
Uh,
this week.
Four times.
Wow.
Your banking,
if you know,
put their go live.
We're streaming live and then afterwards
we'll put it up on itunes and it'll
upload to youtube and a little bit.
You got a whole thing going.
Yeah,
but I have too many guests requests.
It's like there's almost too many and I
love doing it.
So just do a bunch of them.
Who's your favorite guests?
Don't.
Besides countdown.
Second cows on it again.
Oh wow.
This is great.
I don't have one.
I'm so lucky.
I've had so many great guests.
I really don't have a favorite.
Yeah,
you do.
Yeah.
I just never had sam harris through
pretty good gash.
And your impression has replaced her
real voice in my mind if I see her on tv
and why should I got my shy shopping
chain trauma challenge?
Yeah.
I'm not sure what she sounds like
anymore.
It might be different.
So,
um,
do you have mapped out future ones that
you're working on right now?
I have a couple.
I actually have like a song I just
recorded.
I couldn't play the second because I
heard that she hits from the ladies
tees.
No,
I don't.
I don't even want to research it because
I don't want it to not be true,
but that's what I heard.
So I wrote a song about her hitting from
the ladies tees.
Do you have a internet with my phone is
broken.
I need to internet to like a,
like a dual world premier right now.
Okay.
Like a jamie can look something up.
Well no,
it's in my email.
Oh,
you need our wifi password here.
Give it to jamie will type it in there.
Yeah.
What's your phones?
Just it died it.
But it's working.
No,
it,
it doesn't do phone calls.
I got wifi but that's it.
And it dies sometimes for no reason.
I went to the 18 to two store before
this.
I've got to go to the apple store.
That's a major
problem.
This isn't interesting.
But anyway,
power cord next to you too.
I had my phone break.
My phone broken Hawaii because I was aI.
just dropped it too many times.
It started making random phone calls so
I could open the contact screen and
start calling people.
Hang up.
Tara cost somebody else.
I would hang up.
Well,
lucky's,
no one in my contacts I don't like,
but um,
when it did that I had to it and then it
totally stopped where it wouldn't let me
punch in my code to unlock it.
It was just fucked.
Wouldn't recognize my face.
It was like,
fuck you.
It was,
it was dead.
Um,
so I ordered one and I had to get it
shipped and I was in lanai,
which is a really small island,
so it takes a few days to get an iphone
there.
It took three days,
but was beautiful.
Three days.
Best three days of your life days with
no phone chillen yesterday.
I could not.
So funny.
There's a article I just found where he
or she.
I'm sorry,
she was talking about let's vote on it.
She said,
craig,
t nelson,
his comment,
I played golf with you for 30 years
before caitlyn.
Nelson said,
I know how you hit.
So it wasn't prejudice.
He said he wouldn't allow her.
He wouldn't allow her to hit from the.
I think if you're on a wheaties box,
you can't as easily as an athlete.
You can't remember her part.
Jenner said she'd hit from either box
depending on how the group voted and
women's t one.
Oh,
and don't worry.
She dominated everyone on the links.
Both sexes.
Sure.
She's a pro.
She's a fucking olympic gold medalist.
I know.
Even though she's 70 years old and a
woman.
Well she.
She went through puberty as a Michigan.
The men muscles in the main skeleton.
It's all withered away.
Well,
here's some skeletons still there,
but the muscles are gone.
This is the world premier.
I will put the whole thing.
Play a baby.
Well,
I just put on this.
Yeah.
I'm going to shoot the video,
I'm sure.
What is the lady see closer?
I don't play golf.
Twenty,
30 yards closer.
Driving the card.
Let's end with that.
Carl dunnigan.
You're funny,
motherfucker,
man.
I'm glad you listened to that terrible
feeling that you had in the middle of
the night.
I am.
Really?
I'm really glad
you got more songs playing.
No,
I don't know what's going on.
My phone call donegan one on instagram.
Do you have a twitter?
Kyle?
Done again.
Twitter.
Oh,
you got to carl done again on the right
one for twitter,
but.
But I don't really use the kyle done
again on instagram.
He's like in the midwest.
Buy it from them.
Reach out per reel.
I can't change once you get verified,
you can't change this.
You can.
Oh really?
Yeah,
we'll talk after.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll let you know people you can call.
Swipe right my man.
Thank you.
All right buddy.
Everybody else go check out his
instagram page.
It's the best buy.